[soft music] "To What Purpose?"
cue-2
Biography of Emil Fischbacher, Missionary
to China
cue-3
by Marshall Broomhall.
cue-4
Mark fourteen, verse four: "To what
purpose has this waste of ointment been
cue-5
made?"
cue-6
Audio book produced and copyrighted by
scrollreader.com.
cue-7
This book was originally published in
1933.
cue-8
The version you are listening to is the
unabridged original, revised for
cue-9
readability.
cue-10
This brief memorial, "To What Purpose?" is
dedicated to all who have
cue-11
generously given for the spread of the
gospel in China, and in loving memory of
cue-12
Emil Fischbacher's mother, who went to
meet the King and be reunited with her son
cue-13
while this small book was being written.
cue-14
R.W. Church said,
cue-15
"As long as Christianity endures,
cue-16
the heroic life must remain the standard
for all people. Christianity may
cue-17
allow for weakness,
cue-18
but it cannot lower its standard.
cue-19
That standard cannot be moved."
cue-20
The imitation of Christ can only be
written in one way.
cue-21
There is strong temptation to abandon this
heroic ideal.
cue-22
It often seems to fail. It is easily
faked.
cue-23
Its failure can be shameful, and not only
does our desire for comfort lead
cue-24
us away from it, but also our fear of
false appearances, our love of
cue-25
moderation, and our so-called common sense
urge us to settle for less,
cue-26
to aim only for what we think suits our
nature.
cue-27
But the New Testament refuses to meet us
at that lower level.
cue-28
It upholds only the heroic standard as the
only one worthy of the greatness it
cue-29
reveals.
cue-30
Foreword
cue-31
by the author, Marshall Broomhall. Written
on October thirty-first, nineteen
cue-32
thirty-three.
cue-33
Tragic and unexpected events can suddenly
stir us to deep thought.
cue-34
This happened when news reached us of Dr.
Emil Fischbacher's early death,
cue-35
just sixteen months after he arrived in
China.
cue-36
The question, "To what purpose?" naturally
came to mind, and from that
cue-37
question, this little book was born.
cue-38
Some may ask, "What can such a short life
offer to justify yet another
cue-39
publication?"
cue-40
Our answer is that apart from the value of
his life itself, a number of
cue-41
stirring and significant events are
connected to his brief time in the mission
cue-42
field.
cue-43
There was the bombing of Shanghai, his
harsh welcome to China.
cue-44
There was the rare and dangerous journey
across the Gobi Desert, vividly showing
cue-45
one of the many challenges in reaching
Chinese Turkestan with the gospel.
cue-46
Then came the rebellion in that distant
land, a sample of the hard and dangerous
cue-47
work that pioneers may face.
cue-48
All this and more is captured in this
brief account.
cue-49
It has been said of Dante that he believed
wonderful stories could be found in the
cue-50
unnoticed paths of life,
cue-51
in the fleeting events of the moment, and
among people whose faces we have seen.
cue-52
That is why he didn't limit his Divine
Comedy to famous figures.
cue-53
Not only the great and well-known, such a
focus is too narrow and unreal,
cue-54
he believed.
cue-55
He even chose the title Comedy because he
wrote in the language of everyday people,
cue-56
not in Latin, and because he wrote about
common life.
cue-57
In the same way, the short life of this
young doctor carries a unique
cue-58
significance. Its very brevity awakens
reverence and
cue-59
attention. The late Dr. Eugene Stock once
reflected on how some brief
cue-60
missionary lives have had lasting
influence. David Brainerd
cue-61
worked among the Native Americans for less
than three years and died at twenty-nine.
cue-62
Henry Martin served only six years and
died at thirty-one.
cue-63
Bishop Hannington labored in Africa for
about three years before he was killed on
cue-64
the way to his post. These are just a few
from a great number of such lives.
cue-65
Lives cannot be measured by their length.
cue-66
Of David Brainerd, Dr. Stock said,
cue-67
"He did less in his lifetime than his
biography did after he was gone."
cue-68
A single moment of sowing can bring
harvests for generations.
cue-69
Who would measure the life of our Lord by
how long he lived on Earth?
cue-70
We can only trace the surface history.
cue-71
Only love understands the mystery.
cue-72
If this little book can help even one
reader grasp the great importance of
cue-73
bringing the gospel to a land as vast and
remote as Chinese Turkestan,
cue-74
the land for which Emil Fischbacher gave
his life,
cue-75
then its publication will be more than
worthwhile.
cue-76
Chapter one: An Introduction to China.
cue-77
"We've just received news by wireless from
England that China has declared war on
cue-78
Japan.
cue-79
We haven't been able to reach Shanghai for
over forty-eight hours. The captain isn't
cue-80
sure if we'll be able to land.
cue-81
There's a lot of excitement on board."
cue-82
So wrote Emil Fischbacher to his dear
family at home as the SS Naldera
cue-83
steamed up the China Sea, about eighty
miles from the mouth of the Yangtze River.
cue-84
Although no official declaration of war
had been made, fighting had already
cue-85
begun.
cue-86
In another letter written not long after,
he added...
cue-87
"The pilot came on board three or four
hours ago, and apparently, he doesn't know
cue-88
what to do. So here we are and will
likely stay until morning. We
cue-89
still haven't been able to reach Shanghai
by wireless for nearly three days.
cue-90
All our news is coming from England.
cue-91
It seems the government wireless station
in Shanghai has been destroyed.
cue-92
The captain is reluctant to head directly
to Japan.Since he doesn't yet have
cue-93
room for the cargo he's supposed to pick
up there.
cue-94
This morning at seven o'clock, HMS Suffolk
sped past us at thirty knots,
cue-95
headed straight for Shanghai.
cue-96
She'd been in Hong Kong when we left.
She's a large cruiser. Normally,
cue-97
ships in these waters are limited to
thirteen or fourteen knots an hour, so the
cue-98
Suffolk must be heading into serious
action.
cue-99
Emil Fischbacher, the writer of the above,
was one of six young men on board the
cue-100
Naldera, all new volunteers for the great
work of evangelizing China.
cue-101
Three of them, including Emil, were
medical doctors. They were part of the
cue-102
last group of the two hundred and had left
London on the final day of nineteen
cue-103
thirty-one.
cue-104
Their ship had sailed on Christmas Day,
but because of the special meaning of that
cue-105
season, arrangements had been made for
the group to travel overland and board at
cue-106
Marseille.
cue-107
As it turned out, that Christmas was the
last Emil would spend with his family on
cue-108
Earth, and for his loved ones, it had been
an especially joyful and
cue-109
unforgettable time, filled with surprise
and gladness.
cue-110
But now, back on the ship, the passengers
waited anxiously as their vessel
cue-111
lay just beyond the Woosung forts.
cue-112
Although the steamer couldn't go to its
usual dock, passengers were taken up the
cue-113
river on a smaller boat. The group of
young missionaries, accompanied by Mr.
cue-114
and Mrs. Rowe, safely arrived at the new
compound of the China Inland
cue-115
Mission.
cue-116
The old headquarters, only vacated seven
months earlier, had already been taken
cue-117
over by the Japanese.
cue-118
It was inside the area of active conflict.
cue-119
This striking scene gave the new arrivals
a powerful reminder.
cue-120
God had not forgotten his people.
cue-121
He had already made a way for his work to
continue.
cue-122
It was a harsh welcome to a foreign land,
but one that matched the disorder of the
cue-123
vast country they had come to evangelize.
cue-124
For miles, shops were closed.
cue-125
The general post office was shut down due
to its unsafe location.
cue-126
The Chinese banks were not operating. The
customs house mirrored the abnormal
cue-127
state of one of the world's great ports.
cue-128
Letters sent home during this time,
cue-129
letters that had to be smuggled out of
Shanghai, were filled with vivid
cue-130
descriptions of those tense days.
cue-131
One or two more extracts from young
Fischbacher's letters will suffice to
cue-132
paint the picture.
cue-133
It was pretty bad, he wrote, but today,
since daybreak, we've had
cue-134
continuous gunfire. These are big guns.
The Japanese clearly mean business
cue-135
today. The constant booming and the shock
of the explosions have continued all
cue-136
day. Tonight's papers suggest that the
Japanese have blown the Woosung forts to
cue-137
pieces.
cue-138
All of this has come from gunboats on the
river.
cue-139
I've just been up on the roof. The sight
honestly makes you sick. For at least
cue-140
three miles, there's a continuous stretch
of fire. The sky is glowing from it
cue-141
all. There can't be much left standing in
the Chapei district now. It's
cue-142
tragic because, as always, the innocent
are the ones who suffer
cue-143
most.
cue-144
There are thousands and thousands of
refugees everywhere. Every boat that can
cue-145
leave is packed with Chinese trying to
escape the fighting.
cue-146
Everyone here is deeply thankful for this
building.
cue-147
If we had still been in the old mission
compound, we would have had to evacuate
cue-148
almost a week ago.
cue-149
For now, we are safe, though safe is a
relative word.
cue-150
Two shells landed in Sinza Road, just
yards away.
cue-151
Getting into Shanghai had been one
challenge.
cue-152
Getting out and traveling up the river to
the language school in Anking would be
cue-153
another.
cue-154
But before that story begins,
cue-155
and before we trace the records of Emil
Fischbacher's short yet impactful life in
cue-156
China,
cue-157
we must go back.
cue-158
We need to see what it was that led him to
face the hardships and duties of a
cue-159
missionary's calling.
cue-160
As the writer of Ecclesiasticus says,
cue-161
My son, if you come to serve the Lord,
prepare your soul for testing.
cue-162
Jesus, son of Sirach, who wrote those
words, surely spoke from
cue-163
experience.
cue-164
It was wise and weighty counsel, and Emil
Fischbacher had not put his hand to the
cue-165
plow without first fighting a deep battle
in the valley of decision.
cue-166
Chapter two. It might have been.
cue-167
When a woman poured her expensive
spikenard oil on Jesus' head and feet,
cue-168
those who didn't understand were indignant
and said, To what purpose was this waste?
cue-169
This ointment could have been sold for
over three hundred pence.
cue-170
This same false thinking will always exist
wherever spiritual blindness remains.
cue-171
The world especially appeals to the young,
offering them life itself, their most
cue-172
precious treasure.
cue-173
Temporary things dress themselves in
beauty and offer every possible charm.
cue-174
The inner tempter and the pressures from
outside work together, presenting their
cue-175
strongest case against breaking the vessel
of life and pouring out its contents for
cue-176
God.
cue-177
So it was with Emil Fischbacher.
cue-178
The world made him a great offer.
cue-179
He was born into a Christian home, the
fourth son and sixth child in a family of
cue-180
ten.
cue-181
That Emil and all his surviving brothers
and sisters committed themselves to Christ
cue-182
early in life speaks volumes about their
home and their parents' influence.
cue-183
All were baptized by their pastor, the
Reverend John McBeath.
cue-184
We have before us a copy of a covenant
card like the one Emil signed as a young
cue-185
boy. He and his brother Ernest were part
of a group of young people who, on
cue-186
a memorable Sunday, signed those cards
and handed them to the pastor at the
cue-187
pulpit.
cue-188
There was nothing forced or artificial
about it. It was healthy, sincere, and
cue-189
real.Under the covenant and the boy's
signature are these familiar
cue-190
lines.
cue-191
Just as I am, young, strong, and free, to
be the best that I
cue-192
can be, for truth and righteousness and
thee, Lord of my life,
cue-193
I come.
cue-194
And on the back of the card are more
lines,
cue-195
some for the boys and some for the girls,
reminding us of what Hudson Taylor used to
cue-196
say,
cue-197
that conversion should be called becoming
joyful,
cue-198
not becoming serious, as it was often
described in his youth.
cue-199
Here are the lines written for the boys.
cue-200
God wants the boys, the cheerful boys, the
noisy, laughing,
cue-201
playful boys, the careless boys.
cue-202
God wants the boys with all their joys,
that he might make them pure as
cue-203
gold and teach them how to brave and hold
through trial and test with courage
cue-204
bright.
cue-205
To stand for truth, defend the right. God
wants the boys.
cue-206
At home, the cause of foreign missions was
always front and center.
cue-207
Emil's father had one great ambition, that
at least five of his children would offer
cue-208
themselves for missionary service and
that he might have the joy and privilege
cue-209
of supporting them financially without the
need for mission societies.
cue-210
He worked hard and built a successful
business largely for this purpose.
cue-211
China held a special place in his heart,
especially through the work of the China
cue-212
Inland Mission.
cue-213
Yet, as Emil grew older, he strongly
resisted the idea of serving there,
cue-214
even though his eldest sister had already
gone. China was the last place in the
cue-215
world he wanted to go, but this may have
been for the best, because when the
cue-216
decision finally came, it was entirely his
own. Not someone else's,
cue-217
not even subtly suggested.
cue-218
We are given a glimpse of that personal
decision in a letter he wrote to his
cue-219
younger brother, dated February 15th,
1933, from the
cue-220
capital of Chinese Turkestan. It reveals
part, but not all, of
cue-221
the struggle that had taken place between
his soul and God.
cue-222
One thing has been on my mind,
cue-223
and that is foreign missions and your
relationship to them.
cue-224
I knew, of course, that you didn't want to
say much.
cue-225
You always went so far and no further,
cue-226
but I was anxious to know, and I'm glad
you told me. I've been thinking about
cue-227
you a lot recently, and praying too, that
the Lord would open a sphere of
cue-228
service for you.
cue-229
I'm not impatient,
cue-230
but I am praying that the Lord will, in
his time,
cue-231
clearly show you what he wants you to do.
I almost feel as if I make suggestions in
cue-232
my prayers about what kind of service
might suit you,
cue-233
but I whisper them under my breath.
cue-234
I've often thought, ever since I qualified
in 1926, that surely
cue-235
sometime soon I would receive the call.
Even when I wasn't eager,
cue-236
I had the sense that one day I'd find
myself on the foreign field.
cue-237
I would never have imagined that China
would be part of that.
cue-238
As you may know, for three or four years,
Dr. W. wanted me to come and
cue-239
work with him.
cue-240
That would have meant £1,200 a year for
three years, and then over
cue-241
£3,000 a year after that.
cue-242
You can live quite comfortably on an
income like that.
cue-243
But I never felt right about accepting the
offer, because I always had the
cue-244
possibility of the mission field in the
back of my mind.
cue-245
It's strange to think of it now.
cue-246
Dr. W. was very kind about it, even though
he didn't fully understand.
cue-247
In the meantime, I bounced from place to
place.
cue-248
First general practice,
cue-249
then a house surgeon post,
cue-250
then tropical medicine, then general
surgery and major operations,
cue-251
then public health and tuberculosis,
cue-252
then ear, nose and throat diseases,
cue-253
then another stretch of varied general
practice,
cue-254
then eye diseases, and so on and on. What
a mixture!
cue-255
Now I'm a kind of jack-of-all-trades here,
cue-256
my own consultant and advisor, with no one
to turn to. How I
cue-257
value all that varied experience!
cue-258
It's more useful than I ever knew.
cue-259
This long, personal letter, never meant
for public eyes, was written to
cue-260
his brother, but it gives us a rare look
into Emil's inner world.
cue-261
It shows what the world offered him and
what he gave up. At one point,
cue-262
there was even the temptation to serve in
a support role rather than go to the
cue-263
mission field himself, believing he could
do more good by financing
cue-264
others. It might have been sold for 300
pence and given to the poor.
cue-265
But God did not want someone else in his
place.
cue-266
He wanted him.
cue-267
It was at this point that God's hand
guided Emil to China in an
cue-268
unmistakable way.
cue-269
In June 1931, he came across an appeal
printed in China's millions.
cue-270
It was addressed to young men and written
by an anonymous missionary in the field.
cue-271
The article referred to the ongoing appeal
for the 200 and opened with these words.
cue-272
What does that appeal mean to you?
cue-273
Maybe you've had objections to the way the
appeal was made.
cue-274
Will those objections still stand when you
have to answer to the Lord on the coming
cue-275
day?
cue-276
This was an arrow shot from far away,
cue-277
but it struck home.
cue-278
Not even knowing where to apply, Emil
wrote to the author of the booklet,
cue-279
someone who had once stayed in his home
and played golf with him during a visit to
cue-280
Scotland.
cue-281
In that letter, he said
cue-282
I was extremely eager to go to Africa, but
honestly, the idea of going to
cue-283
China never entered my mind. I never even
liked the thought of serving there.
cue-284
But last Saturday evening, I picked up
the latest issue of China's
cue-285
millions and read the appeal to young men.
Since then, I've felt an
cue-286
irresistible urge to write this letter.
cue-287
This was in June, just before the China
Inland Mission Conference at
cue-288
Swanwick. His letter was passed on to the
Reverend W.H. Aldis,
cue-289
home director of the mission's work in
Great Britain.
cue-290
What happened next is best told in Emil
Fischbacher's own words. In a letter he
cue-291
wrote to his younger sister, who was also
in the medical profession.
cue-292
I got a note from Mr. Aldis asking if I
would come over to the CIM conference at
cue-293
Swanwick and meet him.
cue-294
Yesterday was my half day off,
cue-295
so I went.
cue-296
A beautiful drive through Derbyshire,
sixty-one miles.
cue-297
At that time, he was practicing near
Manchester.
cue-298
Right away, I found myself in three
wonderful meetings. At nine fifteen
cue-299
PM, as planned, I met Mr. Aldis and we
went for a walk.
cue-300
Then, in his room, we prayed together. And
now, well, I feel
cue-301
strange. I haven't quite grasped it all
yet. I wish you were here. I'd talk it all
cue-302
out with you. I've been very down for
months and months because I felt I had
cue-303
completely lost my direction. But God has
been good.
cue-304
The letter continues in a free and
open-hearted tone,
cue-305
the way some brothers can write only to a
sister with whom nothing is hidden.
cue-306
At that point, he hadn't even told his
parents. His plan was to break the
cue-307
news to them in person during his next
visit home.
cue-308
And now,
cue-309
the whole tone of the letters changes.
cue-310
Streams have burst forth in the desert,
and a heavy heart has been replaced with
cue-311
overflowing joy.
cue-312
Through his personal letters, we get a
glimpse of his Bühler land.
cue-313
Here's part of what he wrote to the same
sister.
cue-314
At Swanwick, even though we were having a
wonderful time, I felt I wasn't in the
cue-315
place of full blessing. I insisted on
keeping my little right,
cue-316
but I was miserable. Eventually, I went to
my room and had half an hour
cue-317
of heaven. That right just slipped away,
and I haven't wanted it back.
cue-318
God has already given me a hundredfold in
return.
cue-319
I'm already at the point of longing to go
to China. Isn't that strange?
cue-320
I used to hate even the thought of China.
cue-321
The question of being filled with the Holy
Spirit has been on my mind constantly for
cue-322
the past ten days or two weeks. I've
spent a lot of time in prayer
cue-323
about it, but somehow I still feel God has
more for me. He's
cue-324
been so kind.
cue-325
Last night I was facing a big difficulty.
I felt I couldn't move forward unless it
cue-326
was removed. I've never liked the idea of
testing God like some people do.
cue-327
It feels like asking for a sign and too
showy. But walking up the
cue-328
road last night,
cue-329
God put it in my heart to test him in this
way. I prayed before going to bed
cue-330
and went to sleep with calm confidence
that the one who alone could help
cue-331
me, and you can't imagine how big the
request was, would answer my
cue-332
prayer. Just as I was about to turn off
the light, I noticed my daily light.
cue-333
I read the portion for that day, and the
very first paragraph was exactly what I
cue-334
needed.
cue-335
What a God we serve, and to think so few
really know him. I know you'll
cue-336
remember me in prayer, because that
filling of the Spirit is what I deeply
cue-337
need. I've been aware of it for years, but
never really prayed through about it.
cue-338
I remember reading that little book by
Andrew Murray, The True Vine, years
cue-339
ago.
cue-340
It made clear to me how necessary this
filling is. I stayed up most of the
cue-341
night once,
cue-342
then again the next night, and maybe three
or four nights, just waiting
cue-343
on God.
cue-344
But in the end, I gave up.
cue-345
Now I know that if I had, like Jacob,
refused to let go until God gave me
cue-346
the blessing, it would have saved me years
of backsliding, sorrow, and
cue-347
trouble.
cue-348
There's much more that could be quoted
from Emil's letters to this sister and to
cue-349
his youngest brother, but the above is
enough to show that a new day had dawned
cue-350
in his spiritual life.
cue-351
To his own surprise, he found himself
talking to his patients about the things
cue-352
of the Spirit.
cue-353
His joy could not be hidden, for from the
overflow of the heart, the mouth speaks.
cue-354
He even wrote to some of his patients, and
they too were brought into freedom and
cue-355
light. His soul was set free, and he could
sing.
cue-356
Now have I found obedience that is joy,
cue-357
not pain,
cue-358
not conflict of the heart and mind, but
harmony of human soul with God.
cue-359
He understood the words,
cue-360
I delight to do thy will, O my God.
cue-361
Yes, thy law is within my heart.
cue-362
He had let go of the anchor of caution and
had floated into God's vast sea of joy.
cue-363
As mentioned in the first chapter, he had
left his home country on the last day of
cue-364
1931 as part of the final group of the two
hundred.
cue-365
We have already described the harsh
welcome he received when he arrived in
cue-366
Shanghai, so now we continue the story
during the Japanese bombing of Chapei.
cue-367
Chapter 3. The Language School
cue-368
Under normal conditions, new workers go
straight to one of the two language
cue-369
schools in China, one for men, one for
women.
cue-370
But for Emil Fischbacher and his group,
the challenge was not getting into
cue-371
Shanghai, but getting out again.
cue-372
Thankfully, their delay was only about two
weeks, though others weren't as
cue-373
fortunate.
cue-374
After ten days in the tense, war-struck
atmosphere of Shanghai, he wrote home.
cue-375
I've almost gotten used to the gunfire
now,
cue-376
though it still shakes me up a bit at
night.
cue-377
Every so often there's a huge explosion
that feels like it's right outside the
cue-378
window.
cue-379
Sometimes it almost throws me out of bed.
cue-380
It really gets on the nerves.
cue-381
I don't know why they always launch their
big attacks at night.
cue-382
As a doctor, he quickly found work. The
Chinese hospitals were full of wounded
cue-383
soldiers, and the local people couldn't
get medical help.
cue-384
They came to him, and he was also asked to
help with other illnesses.
cue-385
There were also necessary meetings with
leaders of different departments. Writing
cue-386
to his family in a down-to-earth way, he
said
cue-387
"I must say, the people here are amazing.
They'll do anything to help
cue-388
us. You really don't grasp how massive the
China Inland Mission is until you
cue-389
-see the headquarters here in Shanghai."
-Some of those helpful folks were doing all
cue-390
they could to get these young newcomers
off to the language school,
cue-391
but it wasn't easy.
cue-392
After many tries, they finally got berths
booked and all the luggage, handbags and
cue-393
all, loaded onto the ship. But the boat
wasn't leaving until noon the next day, so
cue-394
they stayed at the mission house
overnight.
cue-395
The next day, after hours of persuading
because the ship was docked at the
cue-396
Japanese wharf, the Chinese taxi drivers
finally agreed to take
cue-397
them. But when they arrived, surprise, the
boat had already
cue-398
sailed, luggage and all. A break in the
fighting had given the captain a chance to
cue-399
leave early, and he took it, passengers
or not.
cue-400
It was frustrating but also a little
funny, and the young men began asking
cue-401
around to borrow razors and pajamas until
they could catch up with their bags.
cue-402
Five days later, they tried again, this
time determined to sleep on the boat
cue-403
if needed.
cue-404
But now no amount of pleading or money
could convince the drivers to enter the
cue-405
Japanese-controlled zone. They had no
choice but to hire a river launch and
cue-406
try to make their way to the ship.
cue-407
"It was spooky that night," Emil wrote
home. "With all the delays, it had gotten
cue-408
late.
cue-409
Hardly anyone was out since there was a
ten PM curfew in Shanghai.
cue-410
No one dared be seen outside.
cue-411
We carefully passed at least a dozen or
more warships, Japanese,
cue-412
American, and British, on our way to the
wharf. The Japanese admiral's
cue-413
flagship was just a few yards away, but
nothing happened. We reached our
cue-414
ship, surprised everyone, and were allowed
on board. What a sight we
cue-415
saw. We had to crawl, climb, or squeeze
our way through a huge crowd of
cue-416
people with all their belongings. They
were refugees fleeing Shanghai. This
cue-417
was just a small boat meant for about
twenty-five second class and twenty
cue-418
first class passengers,
cue-419
but there were eight hundred and fifty
refugees on board along with everything
cue-420
they owned. And another relief ship was
coming with one thousand five hundred
cue-421
more. The air was awful. It still lingers
with me,
cue-422
-but at least we were finally on board."
-The next morning, heading down the river,
cue-423
they passed forty to fifty warships,
destroyers, cruisers, battleships,
cue-424
mostly Japanese,
cue-425
but the British were also there. Their own
boat had thick iron plates along the
cue-426
deck to protect against stray bullets.
cue-427
The scene along the river was horrifying.
cue-428
Villages they had seen two weeks earlier
were now burned ruins.
cue-429
The river, once full of boats and people,
was empty and silent.
cue-430
This story reminds us that missionaries in
China, especially those in the forward
cue-431
movement, were facing times as difficult
as Nehemiah when he rebuilt
cue-432
Jerusalem's walls.
cue-433
And to any young person preparing to go to
the mission field, it may be said,
cue-434
if you choose to go with us,
cue-435
following God wherever he leads,
cue-436
be ready for rough roads.
cue-437
But also remember this promise.
cue-438
God is our Father, there as much as here,
and often nearest in the wilderness.
cue-439
Hanking, nearly four hundred miles up the
Yangtze River, had been the men's language
cue-440
school for over forty years.
cue-441
It was first used during the great
missionary wave in 1887, known as the
cue-442
Hundred.
cue-443
When the Two Hundred followed over a
longer period, more housing was added to
cue-444
meet the need.
cue-445
There, among sixty-eight students, Emil
spent the next two months, a much
cue-446
shorter time than most received. He didn't
describe the full journey upriver
cue-447
through lands recently devastated by
floods, the difficult landing where there
cue-448
was no pier, or the narrow, smelly streets
of the city.
cue-449
But he did write about the training center
itself.
cue-450
"Someday, I'll try to draw a map of the
place.
cue-451
It's both a mission station and a training
home.
cue-452
The church here is mostly independent, but
Mr. Martin Shepard spends most of his day
cue-453
with us.
cue-454
Mr. Haywood and Mr. Shepard stay busy just
keeping the classes running.
cue-455
Just think of it. There are seventy-two
foreigners here. Sixty-eight of us are
cue-456
learning the language. We've got seven
Germans, one Swiss, two
cue-457
Swedes, two New Zealanders, eight
Australians, and people from
cue-458
Texas, Arizona, Calgary, the Canadian
prairies,
cue-459
faraway places,
cue-460
four Scotsmen, and the rest are English.
cue-461
Every one of them is great.
cue-462
If people could see this place, they'd
really understand what the forward
cue-463
movement of the CIM is all about. It's
amazing mixing
cue-464
-with so many different nationalities."
-We won't go into the daily routine of the
cue-465
training home or the many observations
Emil made in his letters.
cue-466
But there is one important thing that
reveals his heart and can't be left out.
cue-467
Emil's father had always hoped that his
children who became missionaries would
cue-468
support themselves and not rely on mission
funds.
cue-469
Emil found this idea appealing, but in the
end, he believed that being fully
cue-470
united with his fellow missionaries was a
higher path.
cue-471
For readers who may not know, it's worth
explaining that the mission's position on
cue-472
special support was carefully worked out
by Hudson Taylor nearly forty years
cue-473
earlier.To fully explain the arguments for
and against this issue would
cue-474
require a long article.
cue-475
In short, special financial support was
found to create many problems within a
cue-476
mission based on faith principles.
cue-477
From the general funds, the mission
provided for things like schools for
cue-478
missionaries' children, rest homes for
their health, travel to and from Shanghai,
cue-479
and other travel within China.
cue-480
These funds also covered administration
and the upkeep of mission properties both
cue-481
in China and at home.
cue-482
A missionary's personal expenses were only
part of their overall share in this
cue-483
larger structure. That's only one side of
the matter.
cue-484
After careful thought, Hudson Taylor
concluded that aside from private family
cue-485
arrangements, it was best for churches and
individuals wanting to support a
cue-486
particular missionary to do so through the
general funds on that missionary's
cue-487
behalf.
cue-488
This is a broad overview of a complex
subject. In Emil Fischbacher's case,
cue-489
he would have qualified under the family
exception, a matter on which the mission
cue-490
had no authority to decide.
cue-491
But Emil had so completely embraced the
faith-based principles of the mission that
cue-492
he had no desire to be treated
differently than his fellow workers.
cue-493
His hesitation in accepting his father's
offer led his father to write, saying it
cue-494
was only natural and right for the family
to be his partners, not only in prayer but
cue-495
financially. Emil replied, "Thank you so
much for your promise
cue-496
to be my partner in the work,
cue-497
not only with money but in prayer.
cue-498
I'm beginning to see what that will mean
for me in the days ahead.
cue-499
I've been praying that I might also be a
blessing to you at home. The
cue-500
delay in accepting your offer was simply
because I wasn't sure whether it would be
cue-501
better for the work if I were entirely
independent of the mission, that is
cue-502
directly supported by you or supported
indirectly through the
cue-503
mission. Really, before the Lord, there's
no difference between the two.
cue-504
I saw that being independent had some
advantages, but being a full member of the
cue-505
mission
cue-506
on the exact same terms as the others
might be better for me. Honestly,
cue-507
my natural tendency would be to prefer
full independence. There's
cue-508
something that feels superior about it,
and I'm afraid I've often assumed that.
cue-509
But now that I've joined a faith mission,
cue-510
I don't think I have the right to hold
personal views on how I'd like to be
cue-511
supported.
cue-512
I had to take the matter seriously in
prayer.
cue-513
I hope you'll see from this brief
explanation that it wasn't meant as any
cue-514
kind of slight,
cue-515
but just a matter of how I was relating to
God.
cue-516
You mentioned how you've often wished for
a prayer partner to stand with you in the
cue-517
business.
cue-518
I may not understand the day-to-day
challenges, but I'll gladly take up that
cue-519
role of prayer partner. I'll make it a
special point of daily prayer that God
cue-520
will use you and give you the strength and
grace you need each day."
cue-521
While this question was being worked out
between father and son, Emil went through
cue-522
a time of testing,
cue-523
somewhat like Hudson Taylor experienced
when the Chinese Evangelization Society
cue-524
assumed his father was supporting him, and
his father assumed the society was.
cue-525
Several times, the mission's treasurer in
Shanghai offered financial help, but
cue-526
Emil, waiting to hear from his father,
held back from accepting it.
cue-527
This led to a period of financial
hardship,
cue-528
but it also gave him a special opportunity
to deal with God directly.
cue-529
The experience had both serious and
humorous moments, but the full story can't
cue-530
be told briefly.
cue-531
Writing to his youngest sister, Emil said,
cue-532
"Have you figured out what's going on?
cue-533
Honestly, sometimes I just laugh and
laugh.
cue-534
By the way, please don't say a word about
this. People will just think my letters
cue-535
were delayed. It's not deception. I just
don't want anyone to know what's really
cue-536
going on.
cue-537
But don't think I'm discouraged or
anything like that. I'm feeling great,
cue-538
better than ever.
cue-539
This time in China has been one of the
most precious periods I can remember.
cue-540
I thank and praise the Lord for every step
of the way.
cue-541
I wouldn't have chosen it for myself, but
what a blessing it's been.
cue-542
To have proven God's faithfulness is
something I wouldn't trade for anything."
cue-543
This private matter has been shared here
because it shows who Emil really was,
cue-544
a man who had fully and wholeheartedly
surrendered his life and everything he had
cue-545
to God.
cue-546
Within about six weeks of Emil
Fischbacher's arrival at Genking, Mr.
cue-547
Host, the general director, came up from
Shanghai with Mr. A.B. Lewis to
cue-548
assign the students to their future places
of service.
cue-549
Although it was only early March, it was
important to avoid travel during the
cue-550
intense summer heat, so these assignments
could not be delayed.
cue-551
At this stage, Emil's letters give vivid
glimpses of what designation
cue-552
fever meant in the training home.
cue-553
To interview more than 60 men, discuss
with each one the direction of his life's
cue-554
work, and come to a final decision in
every case was a major task for the
cue-555
mission's leadership and a matter of deep
personal concern for each man.
cue-556
Even before Mr. Host arrived, Emil wrote
home,
cue-557
"I have a strong feeling I'm going to get
the biggest surprise of my life.
cue-558
I really don't know what to think."
cue-559
At Shanghai, he had often been seated next
to Mr. Hunter at meals.
cue-560
"I was always put beside him," he wrote,
and he had begun to wonder if this was
cue-561
intentional.
cue-562
So when Mr. Host arrived, every day of
waiting became more intense.
cue-563
Someone had to be interviewed first, and
someone last.
cue-564
Emil turned out to be the last of all 68
students, and by then,
cue-565
to use his own expression, his designation
temperature was running
cue-566
high.The dinner bell rang before the final
word had been said in his interview,
cue-567
and the conversation could not be
resumed.
cue-568
But Emil had little doubt where he was
going.
cue-569
He wrote to his family with what he had
already learned about Chinese Turkestan.
cue-570
Two things were clear. First, he would be
nearly two thousand miles from his sister
cue-571
in North China, and second,
cue-572
there would be no hope of a hospital in
that remote region for many years.
cue-573
"I had always thought of going to an
established setup," he wrote.
cue-574
"It would be nice to go to a settled
hospital like Gray, Murray, and Pearce,
cue-575
with a senior colleague to take
responsibility.
cue-576
But, well, the work isn't mine.
cue-577
It belongs to the Lord, so he has the
right to place those who would serve him."
cue-578
This was the spirit in which he accepted
everything that followed. He had already
cue-579
surrendered his little bit of right at
Swanwick, so he made no conditions with
cue-580
God. His description of the group chosen
for Sinkiang shows how deeply
cue-581
engaged he was in the assignment.
cue-582
"The Sinkiang party right now," Emil
wrote, "is made up of five men,
cue-583
and they're going up, God willing, with
Mr. Hunter. There's one from Tasmania,
cue-584
Parsons. One from America, Scherner, a
German.
cue-585
One from Australia, but born in China,
Raymond Joyce. One from
cue-586
England,
cue-587
raised in Singapore, Holmes. And one pure
Englishman, Drew.
cue-588
If I go, it'll add even more flavor to
this mix of nationalities.
cue-589
Funny thing, Scherner studied for two
years at Moody Bible Institute with Theo,"
cue-590
Emil's youngest brother. "Isn't that a
coincidence?"
cue-591
Just a week later, an airmail letter from
Shanghai confirmed Emil Fischbacher's
cue-592
assignment to Sinkiang and asked him to
head to the coast without delay.
cue-593
His sister had been called from Shaanxi to
meet him, since with nearly two thousand
cue-594
miles between their stations, the chance
of seeing each other again would be slim.
cue-595
Emil responded quickly.
cue-596
He set his alarm for four AM, and after a
journey that he described as one
cue-597
long jostling match, he safely arrived in
Shanghai once more.
cue-598
Chapter Four: A School of Patience.
cue-599
Being called to Shanghai by airmail
sounded urgent, but China has a way of
cue-600
teaching patience, and those most eager to
serve often feel this lesson most
cue-601
deeply.
cue-602
Though the original purpose was to allow
him and his sister a final meeting before
cue-603
his long journey to Central Asia, no one
imagined that nearly four months would
cue-604
pass before travel was even possible.
cue-605
Before diving into the many challenges of
the journey ahead, we pause to hear how
cue-606
Emil impressed his missionary sister, who
hadn't seen him in years.
cue-607
In a personal letter, she wrote...
cue-608
"I expected to see a big change in my
brother,
cue-609
but until we met, I kept wondering how
much of it would be just redirected
cue-610
interest and energy,
cue-611
and how much would be true spiritual
growth.
cue-612
But even during the short drive from the
wharf to the mission house,
cue-613
I saw enough to fill my heart with joy,
and that joy only deepened with each
cue-614
moment we spent together.
cue-615
Even my Scottish reserve, along with my
practical nature, was stretched to the
cue-616
limit to keep my feelings in check.
cue-617
I had to keep shaking myself to be sure I
wasn't dreaming,
cue-618
and that the man beside me was really the
same brother who had carefully avoided me
cue-619
almost the entire time I was home.
cue-620
In the days we spent together in Shanghai,
I could almost watch him grow.
cue-621
It was one of the most beautiful things
I've ever seen.
cue-622
He had been awakened to the wonder of
spiritual life, and he was pressing on
cue-623
quickly, drawn forward by the vision of
Christ. There were many people and
cue-624
situations to talk about.
cue-625
Though we had only been apart a few years,
we had so much to share of the Lord's
cue-626
grace that even three full weeks in
Shanghai seemed too short for it
cue-627
all. At the very beginning of our time
together, we made a promise
cue-628
that our desire to be with each other
would never stand in the way of meeting
cue-629
anyone else God wanted us to meet,
cue-630
and God brought him quite a few such
encounters. It was a joy to see how
cue-631
seriously my brother took these. One
evening, we were invited to
cue-632
a small gathering of believers.
cue-633
We had hoped for a chance to witness, but
the evening seemed fruitless.
cue-634
Our hearts were heavy as we walked home.
cue-635
Instead of going to bed,
cue-636
we spent time in prayer together. It was
long past bedtime when we finally
cue-637
parted,
cue-638
and when I encouraged him, older sister
style, to get straight to bed,
cue-639
he looked at me with a look I won't forget
and said,
cue-640
'I can't go to bed.'
cue-641
In his final note from Shanghai, hurriedly
written, he still made time to mention
cue-642
two people he had met.
cue-643
One, an assistant at a medical store where
he had shopped, and the other, a
cue-644
Russian chemist.
cue-645
He asked for prayer for both.
cue-646
"The Russian chemist I haven't been able
to speak with again," he wrote.
cue-647
"There's always someone else in the shop,
but I still have a small bill to pay.
cue-648
Maybe I'll get the chance then."
cue-649
So even shopping and settling bills became
opportunities for advancing the Kingdom
cue-650
of God.
cue-651
From the day, a couple of years ago, when
he gave his life fully to God,
cue-652
the Lord tested his surrender to the
utmost.
cue-653
God would not ask of everyone what he
asked of Emil,
cue-654
but what God asked, Emil gave willingly.
When I came to China, God
cue-655
didn't ask anything of me. He only gave.
cue-656
But my brother's coming cost him dearly,
cue-657
cost him at nearly every step.
cue-658
Yet when we knelt together on our first
day in Shanghai, the first time I ever
cue-659
heard him pray,
cue-660
he thanked God with a full heart and said
words I'll never forget.
cue-661
"Lord, it has not been hard at all, none
of it. You've done magnificently."
cue-662
My brother had a deep hunger to know the
one whose love had captured him.
cue-663
So he was allowed to walk the only path
that leads to a deeper knowledge of God,
cue-664
the path of testing. One of his last and
greatest tests was
cue-665
being appointed to Sinkiang.
cue-666
Unlike me, Emil was very social, very
affectionate,
cue-667
and for that reason and others, his whole
being recoiled at the idea of
cue-668
Sinkiang when it was first suggested.
cue-669
For some, Sinkiang might hold a sense of
adventure, but for him, there was no
cue-670
thrill,
cue-671
except the thrill of once again
surrendering his will to God. As soon as
cue-672
he recognized the call as from God, he
accepted it with joy.
cue-673
He wrote that it had become to him the
good, acceptable, and perfect will
cue-674
of God,
cue-675
acceptable simply because it was the will
of the one he loved.
cue-676
The major question now was
cue-677
how to get to Sinkiang given the difficult
circumstances.
cue-678
There were three possible routes. Through
Kansu, the large northwestern province of
cue-679
China.
cue-680
It was slow but had traditionally been
reliable.
cue-681
However, at that time, war had made this
path impassable.
cue-682
Through India, crossing the vast mountain
range to the north.
cue-683
This was extremely difficult and only open
for travel during a short window each
cue-684
year.
cue-685
Via Siberia, the longest route but the
most feasible under the circumstances.
cue-686
The Trans-Siberian Railway offered a way
to cover much of the distance more
cue-687
quickly.
cue-688
This third route was the one most desired.
cue-689
As early as April, an application had been
submitted to the Russian authorities for
cue-690
permission and for a passport visa. But
the process dragged on with
cue-691
endless delays, references sent to Moscow,
and many unknowns.
cue-692
Eventually, the disappointing truth became
clear.
cue-693
Soviet officials were unwilling to
cooperate with anything connected to
cue-694
religious work.
cue-695
So that door was firmly shut. What now?
cue-696
Since the mission had committed, after
much prayer and thought, to a definite
cue-697
forward movement into Chinese Turkestan,
cue-698
it didn't seem right to simply wait for
doors to open.
cue-699
As early as April, Mr. G. Findlay Andrew,
who had vast experience traveling in
cue-700
China, even by air and motor,
cue-701
quietly said to Dr. Fischbacher,
cue-702
"Why not go by Mongolia?"
cue-703
To some, this sounded like choosing to die
in the desert.
cue-704
It was true that others had crossed that
way, but only with large, costly
cue-705
expeditions.
cue-706
The Citroën Trans-Asiatic Expedition, for
instance, had nine trained mechanics
cue-707
and seven tractor-type vehicles.
cue-708
Dr. Sven Hedin had also crossed the Gobi
Desert, but his mission was
cue-709
well-funded and included scientists from
five nations.
cue-710
Anything remotely like that scale was
completely out of reach,
cue-711
and without such extensive resources, the
risk seemed too great,
cue-712
perhaps even irresponsible.
cue-713
Those who knew the desert best understood
its dangers most clearly.
cue-714
But Emil Fischbacher, though he knew
nothing about the route itself, had strong
cue-715
technical knowledge of vehicles.
cue-716
Mr. Andrew's suggestion took hold of him,
and he quietly began researching and
cue-717
planning. He even sent drawings home of
the type of truck he hoped to use.
cue-718
In a letter dated June fourteenth, he
shared detailed calculations,
cue-719
petrol consumption, fuel weight, baggage
allowances, the kind of vehicle he
cue-720
favored, and the spare parts they would
need: propeller shafts, back
cue-721
axles, crown wheels, differential gears,
pistons, connecting
cue-722
rods, piston ring valves, bolts, nuts, and
ditch recovery tools
cue-723
like planks, spades, picks, chains, and
ropes.
cue-724
He mentioned that three in the group could
drive.
cue-725
One was an engineer and another a
carpenter.
cue-726
Then writing to his youngest brother, he
added,
cue-727
"Do you think we're a scatterbrained lot?
Really, we're just eager to get there as
cue-728
soon as we can, and this long delay seems
to be God's way of telling us to at
cue-729
least consider other options. Every route
has its problems, but Mongolia,
cue-730
while not without risk, seems the least
difficult overall."
cue-731
In the end, the plan was officially
approved.
cue-732
Emil Fischbacher, because of his technical
background, was given the responsibility
cue-733
of purchasing the vehicles and equipment.
cue-734
In many ways, this journey was unlike
anything in the mission's previous
cue-735
experience.
cue-736
Usually, young missionaries were entirely
dependent on experienced leaders.
cue-737
But in this case, while Mr. George Hunter,
a veteran of over forty years in
cue-738
China and the only one who knew the local
languages, was the team leader,
cue-739
he had to rely fully on Emil for all
technical and transport matters.
cue-740
Mr. Hunter had been so long buried in
Central Asia that he hadn't visited the
cue-741
coast in twenty-five years.
cue-742
The young missionaries, on the other hand,
knew nothing of Central Asia or its ways.
cue-743
To prepare for the journey, Emil bought a
football for
cue-744
exercise during long stretches in the Gobi
Desert. But to anyone steeped in old
cue-745
Chinese culture, this seemed shocking and
out of place.
cue-746
That small detail helps show just how much
this mission was an adventure of grace as
cue-747
well as of faith.
cue-748
Missionaries don't stop being human just
because they cross the sea.
cue-749
And if the generational gap is sometimes
difficult back home, the clash between
cue-750
East and West, between centuries of
difference, is even more profound.
cue-751
On August sixteenth, Emil Fischbacher was
finally able to send home his first letter
cue-752
from Peking, PeipingHe rejoiced that at
last, a real
cue-753
move toward the field had begun.
cue-754
Since we will later let Emil tell the
story of the journey himself,
cue-755
only a few personal and technical notes
from his private letters are mentioned
cue-756
here.
cue-757
From his last letter in Shanghai.
cue-758
I've long since broken all records for the
longest stay in Shanghai.
cue-759
No new worker has ever been held up so
long.
cue-760
Imagine,
cue-761
I've been out over six months, and more
than four of those have been spent in this
cue-762
city.
cue-763
I can wander around Shanghai now with my
eyes practically closed.
cue-764
During this long stay, Emil had served as
transport manager and had come to know the
cue-765
city well.
cue-766
Regarding the unrest in China, which had
to be factored into their journey, he
cue-767
wrote.
cue-768
Three weeks ago, Mr. Simpson was shot
dead, and just three days ago, we heard
cue-769
that Mr. Tornvall, one of our associate
missionaries, and three companions were
cue-770
also killed. Things are very unsettled.
There's also a fierce cholera
cue-771
epidemic raging. We've just received word
that three missionaries have died.
cue-772
-They were also associates.
-Emil also wrote to his medical sister
cue-773
about not expecting a hospital in Sinkiang
for some time. His words show a deep
cue-774
shift in purpose.
cue-775
I don't want a hospital now. My mind has
been completely changed on that. I'm
cue-776
truly out for souls. Don't think I've
gone batty. I really haven't.
cue-777
In a small way, the Lord has given me a
vision of the need for souls and something
cue-778
of the joy of leading others to Him. I
love medicine. I often
cue-779
long to have a scalpel in my hand again,
but I never want it to take over all my
cue-780
time.
cue-781
It's a wonderful tool, surely God-given,
cue-782
but it's not the goal itself.
cue-783
I wouldn't write this to anyone but you
and Theo.
cue-784
The balance between the spiritual and
professional aspects of medical missions
cue-785
has long been discussed.
cue-786
Since God created man both body and
spirit, healing the body alone can
cue-787
never be the full aim.
cue-788
Yet medicine is more than just a splendid
weapon. That phrase doesn't
cue-789
capture the ministry of the Great
Physician or the care of a loving mother
cue-790
for her child's health.
cue-791
Such love is not merely a tool. It is an
expression of God's own heart.
cue-792
Emil's words show a healthy resistance to
the danger every medical missionary faces,
cue-793
the temptation to let the profession
overshadow the mission.
cue-794
He did not want medicine to monopolize his
time.
cue-795
There are always two ways to go wrong in a
calling that touches both body and soul.
cue-796
We keep our balance in life not by
standing still, but by a constant series
cue-797
of corrections, even while walking. So it
is in every calling, especially
cue-798
one that seeks to advance.
cue-799
In less than twelve months, Emil would lay
down his life through exhausting service
cue-800
to men broken by war. With his God-given
skill, he could not have done
cue-801
otherwise. Whether the wounded soldiers
were able to hear the gospel or whether
cue-802
there was time for words at all doesn't
change what they experienced.
cue-803
The love of God moving through the
surgeon's hands.
cue-804
In those final difficult months,
cue-805
Emil Fischbacher never spoke more
powerfully of Christ than through the way
cue-806
he served.
cue-807
Of old, the sick hoped that even the
shadow of Peter might fall on them,
cue-808
and in the Crimea, wounded men blessed the
shadow of Florence Nightingale's lamp
cue-809
as she moved among them at night.
cue-810
It is the spirit that gives life.
cue-811
It is the touch that tells.
cue-812
This crust is my body broken for thee.
cue-813
This water, his blood that died on the
tree. The Holy Supper is kept,
cue-814
indeed, in whatso we share with another's
need.
cue-815
Not what we give, but what we share.
cue-816
For the gift without the giver is bare.
cue-817
Who gives himself with his alms feeds
three.
cue-818
Himself, his hungering neighbor,
cue-819
and me.
cue-820
After briefly considering the spiritual
side of medical work, we now turn to some
cue-821
seemingly more ordinary matters.
cue-822
But we don't need to be concerned about
this shift. The poet George Herbert
cue-823
spoke of an elixir that makes drudgery
divine, and of that famous stone that
cue-824
turns all to gold.
cue-825
For whatever God touches and claims as his
cannot be called less than holy.
cue-826
Now, we turn to dealing with the sand of
the desert, no small issue, and in this
cue-827
matter, he earnestly sought God's
guidance.
cue-828
One expedition across the Gobi Desert had
all their pistons and cylinders destroyed
cue-829
because sand got in and quickly wore them
out.
cue-830
This led to the need for special springs
and special air and oil filters.
cue-831
Thankfully, he was helped by some
experienced advisors.
cue-832
Mr. Findlay Andrew suddenly turned up in
Peking the other day, and I spent a couple
cue-833
of hours discussing things with him. He's
had lots of experience with this kind of
cue-834
travel, though he hasn't crossed the Gobi
himself.
cue-835
Soderbom, a fellow Shaofu schoolboy,
Findlay Andrew, and I had lunch together
cue-836
at a hotel. They shared so many
experiences that will be a huge help.
cue-837
Findlay Andrew once drove a Ford truck up
to Lanzhou and had to dismantle the engine
cue-838
three times along the way.
cue-839
Soderbom, who crossed the Gobi with Sven
Hedin, told of a time at Etsingol
cue-840
when his car got stuck in river mud and
slowly sank until only the top of the
cue-841
windshield showed. Thankfully, the river
wasn't deep, but he had to wait until a
cue-842
dozen or more camels could pull it out.
And of course, the engine had to be
cue-843
completely taken apart afterwards.
cue-844
Then Emil adds almost cheerfully.
cue-845
Well, we're going to have quite the
picnic, aren't we? We're all young, and we
cue-846
get along very well.
cue-847
Finally, knowing Sinkiang's strict
censorship, Emil warned his family that
cue-848
they should expect long silences from him
once he arrived, and not to be alarmed.
cue-849
Besides physical and mechanical dangers,
there was also human danger on the
cue-850
road. A report from the Citroën
expedition, which had crossed the Gobi
cue-851
only six months before Emil's group, told
this chilling story.
cue-852
Soon after midnight, we crossed into Inner
Mongolia and stopped at an inn near the
cue-853
Ula Shan.
cue-854
The next day, a 1919 Dodge arrived,
crammed with twenty-two men
cue-855
so covered in dust they looked like
statues.
cue-856
They were headed for Linggi Chang.
cue-857
Before reaching it, three were killed, and
the rest were robbed of everything.
cue-858
Such facts underline the serious risk
cue-859
and highlight the merciful protection that
rested on the missionary team.
cue-860
The good hand of God was upon them.
cue-861
[gentle music] Chapter Five: Crossing the
Gobi Desert.
cue-862
This whole chapter is taken from Dr. E.
Fishbucker's circular letter.
cue-863
On August 13th, at Mr. Host's request,
cue-864
I traveled with Mr. Hunter to Peiping,
Peking, to meet Mr.
cue-865
Soderbom and make the necessary plans and
purchases for our long journey through the
cue-866
desert. There were many such plans and
purchases. Each time I thought
cue-867
of something we'd need, I wrote it in a
notebook. Before long, the list
cue-868
was too long for one person to manage. So
when the rest of the team arrived, we
cue-869
divided the work.
cue-870
Otto Schoerner took responsibility for the
food supplies. Drew was in charge of
cue-871
heating and lighting. Holmes became our
chief engineer. Parsons looked after
cue-872
the supply of petrol, oil, radiator water,
and tire air.
cue-873
Joyce became the head packer and also our
lead journalist. These titles were meant
cue-874
humorously, but the division of labor
made everything run smoothly and saved us
cue-875
a lot of time. For the trip, we bought a
large tent big enough for seven
cue-876
people, ropes for packing and towing,
picks, a shovel, a
cue-877
spade, Mongol fire-making tools, sheepskin
sleeping bags, and
cue-878
much more. For the vehicles, we carried
many spare parts,
cue-879
tires, springs, axle shafts, bearings, and
various electrical
cue-880
items. We had to take all the petrol we
would need for the roughly thousand-mile
cue-881
journey.
cue-882
This,
cue-883
along with the necessary oil, weighed
nearly four thousand pounds. Spare
cue-884
parts, food, and other gear added another
one thousand pounds.
cue-885
On top of that was the weight of eight
strong men,
cue-886
six of whom brought all their belongings
with them.
cue-887
That's why we bought two trucks, each able
to carry one and a half tons. There
cue-888
were many challenges, but the Lord gave us
grace and wisdom.
cue-889
The truck chassis had to be shipped from
Shanghai to Tientsin
cue-890
while the truck bodies were being built in
Tientsin.
cue-891
Once the chassis arrived, the trucks were
assembled, engines tuned, and
cue-892
extras added.
cue-893
Exactly fourteen days after we placed the
order,
cue-894
I went from Peiping to Tientsin with
Holmes to collect the trucks. It was a
cue-895
remarkable achievement and showed the
skill of the American Chinese company that
cue-896
built them. We drove the eighty or so
miles from Tientsin to Peiping,
cue-897
and the trucks ran beautifully. It was my
first time on Chinese roads,
cue-898
and I was pleasantly surprised.
cue-899
I had thought my driving days were behind
me, but it was such a joy to be behind the
cue-900
wheel again.
cue-901
The cabs were very comfortable, and with a
four-speed gearbox and excellent
cue-902
suspension, they felt much like a light
car.
cue-903
I thoroughly enjoyed the trip, especially
since Miss Deck from Kiwo,
cue-904
Shansi,
cue-905
rode with me and even took the wheel for a
while, driving like an expert.
cue-906
It's hard to write everything I want to
tell you. There's just not enough space.
cue-907
Please understand, if I seem to go on a
bit, that between any two events I
cue-908
mention, there were often many others that
also deserve telling.
cue-909
Some things have to be included,
cue-910
even if they seem small, because they help
complete the picture of what
cue-911
happened. On the evening of September
eighth, we loaded the trucks
cue-912
onto railway flat cars to begin our
journey.
cue-913
The experience was unforgettable and
exciting. The trucks had no
cue-914
sides, so we had an open view the entire
way.
cue-915
The scenery, especially through the Nankau
Pass, was
cue-916
beautiful. Picture us eating lunch on the
open railway car,
cue-917
one person sitting on the radiator,
another on the bumper, another on the
cue-918
wing,
cue-919
someone on the running board, and two
squatting on the floor with their legs
cue-920
hanging over the side. Unusual?
cue-921
Yes, but so enjoyable. We had little
trouble getting
cue-922
the vehicles from the railway station to
the Methodist Mission compound, where we
cue-923
stayed as guests of Mr. and Mrs. Soderbom
and Mr.
cue-924
and Mrs. Williams. I cannot fully express
how kind they were to us,
cue-925
but I must give special thanks to Mr.
Soderbom Senior,
cue-926
who worked tirelessly during the three
days we stayed there. His greatest help
cue-927
was in securing the necessary licenses for
both the drivers and the vehicles.
cue-928
He also helped us greatly in finalizing
arrangements with our Mongol
cue-929
guide, whom we had hired on the
recommendation of Mr. George Soderbom.
cue-930
While in Tientsin,
cue-931
I'd been warned that one of our biggest
challenges would be getting through the
cue-932
customs barrier at Kalgan.
cue-933
I wrote to Mr. Broomhall in Shanghai,
asking for special prayer on this matter.
cue-934
Those of you who have been praying for us
may notice in this letter many clear
cue-935
answers to prayer.
cue-936
Sadly, because of censorship-I can't
mention many of the things that
cue-937
meant the most to us, but here's one
example. It took us just ten minutes
cue-938
from the time we reached the customs
barrier to the moment we shook hands and
cue-939
continued on our way into what would
become our new homeland.
cue-940
So it was that on the morning of September
13th, we began our unforgettable
cue-941
journey. The first day gave us our
introduction to Mongolian roads.
cue-942
At the time, we weren't impressed at all,
but looking back now, we'd almost have
cue-943
to call it first class. The road twisted
and turned, was full of
cue-944
bumps, and had many steep climbs, which
meant a lot of driving in low gear.
cue-945
Since the engines were new and the
bearings tight, we had to stop several
cue-946
times due to overheating. Thankfully,
water was easy to find,
cue-947
so all we needed was a little patience,
especially since we knew the
cue-948
engines would soon settle in. Just as
night was falling, we saw a small
cue-949
village called Haishuihou, where we
decided to stop.
cue-950
I'd heard many stories about Chinese inns,
but this first experience was a very
cue-951
pleasant surprise. The cars drew much
attention as we unloaded what we needed
cue-952
and got ready for dinner. We washed,
cooked, ate, and got ready for bed, all
cue-953
under the curious eyes of a group of
Mongol onlookers. I was interested to read
cue-954
in my diary for September 13th, Going
over pass to Changpei
cue-955
Hsien, the toughest climb I've ever faced.
What a surface!
cue-956
One car hit a mud hole and got stuck.
cue-957
Our first digging-out practice.
cue-958
Compared to what came later, that first
day would almost count as good going.
cue-959
Still, the fact that we only managed
fifty-four miles shows you how rough the
cue-960
road was.
cue-961
I also noted in my diary that the cost of
the inn for the night was just one dollar
cue-962
sixty cents total,
cue-963
about three days each.
cue-964
And before we left, we bought a sack of
potatoes for forty cents,
cue-965
about five and a half days. That sack of
potatoes lasted us all the
cue-966
way to Hami.
cue-967
During the journey, we always referred to
the vehicles as either Holmes' car or
cue-968
Fishbacker's car,
cue-969
and for clarity, I'll continue using that
distinction. Each of
cue-970
us usually drove the same vehicle, with
Parsons and I rarely
cue-971
switching. In fact, all the younger
members of the team took turns driving
cue-972
before we reached our destination. A
minor problem with Holmes' car delayed us
cue-973
briefly.
cue-974
That afternoon, we stopped for a short
rest at Hatin Sumu, a small Mongol
cue-975
settlement. The Swedish-Mongol mission
there is doing excellent work, and we were
cue-976
warmly welcomed by the Mongol pastor and
a group of schoolchildren.
cue-977
Later that evening, we came across the
camp of Mr. Larson,
cue-978
nicknamed the Duke of Mongolia, who had
once been part of the Sven Hedin
cue-979
expedition.
cue-980
With him were Mr. Lattimore,
cue-981
author of The Desert Road to Turkestan,
and his wife.
cue-982
Mr. Hunter had met Mr. Lattimore years
earlier during travels in Sinkiang, and
cue-983
they enjoyed catching up and sharing
memories.
cue-984
The next day, we traveled through rolling
steppe country,
cue-985
mostly good terrain. But when I say good
roads, don't picture anything like the
cue-986
main highways between Scotland and
England.
cue-987
According to my diary,
cue-988
I once dared to reach twenty-four miles
per hour that day, but the speed felt
cue-989
so reckless that I quickly slowed to our
usual fifteen to twenty miles per hour.
cue-990
The surface demanded constant attention. A
single careless moment could have led
cue-991
to serious trouble,
cue-992
even on these good stretches. As the sun
began to set and we crested a
cue-993
hill,
cue-994
we saw what looked like a beautiful little
city tucked into the landscape just a
cue-995
mile or two ahead.
cue-996
Our guide told us it was Sharamuren. What
we thought was a town turned
cue-997
out to be a large lamassery, a monastery.
We were told the lamas
cue-998
weren't particularly friendly to
outsiders, so we crossed the nearby river
cue-999
and camped safely beyond it. That day, we
managed to cover another one
cue-1000
hundred miles. The next morning, I vividly
remember stepping out of the
cue-1001
tent and seeing the rising sun shining on
the monastery's pure white walls
cue-1002
and ornate buildings. It was a strange
sight, such an elaborate place
cue-1003
so far from any other sign of
civilization. Around this time, we began
cue-1004
to worry about our fuel supply. We were
using much more petrol than expected,
cue-1005
and it became increasingly clear that we
wouldn't have enough to reach Urumtsi at
cue-1006
our current rate. So it was a great relief
when we reached Baili Miao, an
cue-1007
important caravan crossroads, and were
able to buy fifty gallons of
cue-1008
petrol. For reference, we had estimated
our total need at
cue-1009
around three hundred and sixty gallons,
but to be safe, we carried four hundred
cue-1010
and fifty. As you'll see later, even the
five hundred gallons we
cue-1011
eventually had wasn't enough to complete
the journey.
cue-1012
Leaving Baili Miao, we followed the camel
route toward Etsingol, passing
cue-1013
many travelers, mostly Mongols,
cue-1014
riding camels, horses, donkeys, or
traveling on foot
cue-1015
and by cart.
cue-1016
That day, we covered one hundred and ten
miles and camped in a small place called
cue-1017
Chindamun, where there were only two or
three Mongol yurts. Yangchang
cue-1018
Tsigo
cue-1019
is the title written in our diaries for
Saturday, September 17th.
cue-1020
Our official journalist simply wrote,
cue-1021
Sandy, rocky, lumpy riverbed, twenty-four
miles of it.
cue-1022
But for all of us,
cue-1023
Yangchang Tsigo was more like a nightmare.
cue-1024
It was the hardest section we had faced up
to that point.I don't want to imply that
cue-1025
we were expert drivers or make much of our
efforts, but I do want you to see how
cue-1026
clearly we were protected in situations
where a single mistake could have ended in
cue-1027
disaster. That evening, we crossed a wide
riverbed and entered a
cue-1028
narrow gully with deep, loose sand. Both
vehicles became
cue-1029
hopelessly stuck. Only after much
digging, engine straining, and
cue-1030
pushing were we able to get one vehicle
onto firm ground. We then
cue-1031
had to tow the second one out, our first
time needing to do so.
cue-1032
Sunday was a restful day spent in camp.
cue-1033
A few Mongols passed by now and then, and
we were able to buy a sheep for seven
cue-1034
dollars, about eight shillings.
cue-1035
Seret, our guide, butchered and cooked it,
preparing excellent mutton and
cue-1036
soup. We thoroughly enjoyed the meal.
cue-1037
From my diary on Monday, September
nineteenth: A day of
cue-1038
disappointments, and yet how can we help
praising the Lord for His goodness and
cue-1039
protection over us? All the oiling,
greasing, and inspecting I did on the
cue-1040
transmission couldn't uncover the cause of
a troubling knocking noise in my
cue-1041
car. Sometimes it seemed to come from the
back axle,
cue-1042
other times from the universal joint.
cue-1043
We set off at nine-thirty AM, going
slowly. The terrain was
cue-1044
unlike anything I've ever seen. The car
tilted dangerously time and again.
cue-1045
Once, I went ahead and got stuck in sand,
but managed to free
cue-1046
myself with some effort.
cue-1047
Later, Holmes' car also sank deep into
sand,
cue-1048
and we could only get it out after a lot
of digging and by using our long canvas
cue-1049
strips, about a yard wide, reinforced with
rope.
cue-1050
We all agreed they were worth their weight
in gold.
cue-1051
Two hours later, we got stuck again, this
time in mud.
cue-1052
Holmes took a different route and was able
to tow me out.
cue-1053
A little while later, I hit a deep mud
hole.
cue-1054
After half an hour of hard work with pick
and shovel, I finally got free again.
cue-1055
The knocking sound in my car worsened
until,
cue-1056
by one-thirty PM, we decided to stop. We
had only covered
cue-1057
sixteen miles in four hours.
cue-1058
The next day, we woke to a violent wind
and heavy rain, which made it impossible
cue-1059
to work on the vehicle.
cue-1060
The downpour lasted until late in the
afternoon, so we went to bed without
cue-1061
making progress. But in the morning, the
weather had changed completely. The day
cue-1062
was bright and clear. After a quick check
of the car, we realized we would
cue-1063
have to remove the back axle and torque
rod to find the problem. It was a big
cue-1064
job, but everyone got to work, and by
midday, the axle was free from the
cue-1065
chassis. The differential was in perfect
condition, but after some
cue-1066
searching, we found the trouble. A bearing
in the universal joint had come loose
cue-1067
because its retaining spring was missing.
cue-1068
Finding a replacement spring in the middle
of Mongolia seemed impossible, but that
cue-1069
very morning, we had a small misfortune.
Someone broke a thermos flask.
cue-1070
Seret quickly picked up the broken pieces
and pulled out the small spring
cue-1071
inside. With a bit of heating and bending,
we shaped it into exactly the size we
cue-1072
needed. It worked perfectly. Putting
everything back together took time and
cue-1073
careful effort, but with many hands
helping, the job was finished by
cue-1074
nightfall, and the back axle was fully
restored.
cue-1075
Let me again quote from my diary for
September twenty-second.
cue-1076
I wish I could introduce my friends to a
Mongolian dawn.
cue-1077
Sunrise at six-thirty, glorious.
cue-1078
Had a few issues with small repairs on the
car, but finished by eleven-thirty.
cue-1079
Set off at two PM. Good progress for a
while, but then hit a few miles
cue-1080
of jungle. While driving along the edge of
a dried-up riverbed, the bank
cue-1081
suddenly gave way, and the rear of the car
slipped over. The two boys
cue-1082
riding on top quickly jumped off, and
thankfully, the car came to rest on the
cue-1083
back axle, though at a dangerously steep
angle. The doors were jammed shut,
cue-1084
so Seret, Joyce, and I had to scramble out
through the near side window. I've never
cue-1085
seen a car so close to flipping over. It
was another clear sign of the Lord's great
cue-1086
protection.
cue-1087
Sometimes, I could almost feel the prayers
being lifted up for us. I thought it
cue-1088
might take twenty-four hours to get the
car out, but in just two and a half hours,
cue-1089
we managed to build a road behind it and
drive it back up.
cue-1090
Karat was the mastermind. An impressive
bit of work.
cue-1091
We set up camp, having covered only
twenty-eight miles.
cue-1092
The next day, we managed to cover a bit
more ground.
cue-1093
My diary entry from September twenty-third
says, Up at four-fifteen
cue-1094
AM. Brr, bitterly cold, but a beautiful
moon overhead.
cue-1095
Later, seven PM. What a day. We did
seventy miles in eleven
cue-1096
hours, but less than five of those were in
top gear. Each car used
cue-1097
sixteen gallons of petrol. Road building
became our main task. The
cue-1098
terrain is beyond description. Never
imagined a car, let alone a
cue-1099
two-ton truck, could pass through it.
cue-1100
On the twenty-fourth, we were up again at
five AM and on the road shortly after
cue-1101
seven. The landscape was quite
mountainous, with many dried-up riverbeds.
cue-1102
Later in the day, we entered a riverbed
that looked promising, smooth, and
cue-1103
open. We made good progress for a few
miles, but suddenly, without
cue-1104
warning, my car sank to the axles in thick
mud. I jumped
cue-1105
out, only to find that the second car was
also stuck.
cue-1106
Every attempt to lift the vehicles with
jacks failed. The jacks just sank further
cue-1107
under the weight. It was clear we couldn't
go forward in the riverbed, so we began
cue-1108
building a road out of it.
cue-1109
We had to cut away a three-foot bank and
build a sloping ramp up to firm
cue-1110
ground.We dug out deep channels for the
wheels and filled them with
cue-1111
stones and brushwood.
cue-1112
At that point, we expected to spend the
whole weekend stuck in that awful river,
cue-1113
so it was a great relief, almost a
celebration,
cue-1114
when after five and a half hours of
digging, shoveling, and hauling
cue-1115
stones, we finally got both cars onto
solid ground. Hats flew into the
cue-1116
air, and our Mongol guide shouted, "Let's
go." We then faced
cue-1117
six miles of true cross-country driving,
all in second gear,
cue-1118
followed by yet another riverbed crossing.
cue-1119
Finally, we reached the Gobi Desert
proper. Just beyond the river, we made
cue-1120
camp.
cue-1121
Our speedometers only registered thirty
miles for the entire day,
cue-1122
but we felt more than satisfied.
cue-1123
Overall, the surface of the Gobi was
better than what we had experienced
cue-1124
earlier, but it brought its own set of
problems. In many places, the ground
cue-1125
was so soft that even walking caused us to
sink to our ankles. You can
cue-1126
imagine what that meant for a two-ton
truck, and yet time and
cue-1127
again, the vehicles, though often sunken
nearly to the axles, kept
cue-1128
pushing forward. It was a hard test, and
we were continually
cue-1129
amazed at how well the trucks performed
under such harsh conditions. We also
cue-1130
encountered patches of deep sand, which
often forced us to take long
cue-1131
detours to avoid getting stuck. My diary
entry for September twenty-sixth
cue-1132
reads, "Utterly tired out, and it’s my
turn to wash the dishes. Too
cue-1133
tired to cook much.
cue-1134
Wish Miss Anderson, Shanghai, could have
seen how much we enjoyed her
cue-1135
tea. Lots of digging and pushing today.
Incredible to watch these big
cue-1136
trucks,
cue-1137
sunk nearly to the axles in that soft
gypsum soil that’s so common in the
cue-1138
Gobi, still pressing on. Had a stretch of
two and a half miles in
cue-1139
first gear,
cue-1140
flat out, the engine working its hardest,
and that alone used over two gallons
cue-1141
of petrol." I mention that to show just
how much fuel we were consuming under
cue-1142
such conditions. At this point, we
realized we didn’t have enough petrol
cue-1143
even to reach Hami, but the Lord reminded
me of that verse from John ten, verse
cue-1144
four:
cue-1145
"When he puts forth his own sheep, he goes
before them."
cue-1146
Even though there was little hope of
finding fuel in this remote part of the
cue-1147
world, I felt completely at peace leaving
the matter in the hands of the Lord, who
cue-1148
had already guided us so clearly. The
morning of the
cue-1149
twenty-seventh brought fresh trouble.
cue-1150
Just as we were setting off at nine AM,
cue-1151
my car got stuck in soft ground after
moving less than five yards.
cue-1152
Once we got going again, we had to take a
four-mile detour to avoid another bad
cue-1153
patch ahead.
cue-1154
Later, we stopped for quite some time to
decide on our route.
cue-1155
In front of us were the wide tracks left
by the Citroën expedition that had
cue-1156
come through about three years before.
They used vehicles fitted with caterpillar
cue-1157
tracks. Drew commented that it looked
like Clapham Junction, and it really did.
cue-1158
The ground was very soft, but we managed
to cross safely.
cue-1159
Shortly afterward, the fan bearing in my
car seized.
cue-1160
On checking, I found that the rubber from
the fan belt had almost completely
cue-1161
melted. That gives you some idea of what
these vehicles were being put through.
cue-1162
A note from my diary for September
twenty-eighth shows a different side of
cue-1163
the journey. "This is the loveliest camp
we’ve had,
cue-1164
tucked right away in the hills. Likely not
another living soul for miles and
cue-1165
miles. Brought out the football and had a
proper stretch, just like
cue-1166
back at the Anking Training Home."
cue-1167
Of course, we’d had plenty of physical
labor, but this was a refreshing change.
cue-1168
Although I’ve shared many of the
difficulties we faced and the hard work
cue-1169
involved, I don’t want you to think we
didn’t enjoy the journey.
cue-1170
I’ve often found myself wishing to be back
on the road again,
cue-1171
and more than once, I’ve heard others in
the group say, "Oh, for the Gobi again."
cue-1172
I haven’t written much about the scenery.
cue-1173
That’s something others have described
more, but I can’t end this letter without
cue-1174
quoting a few lines from my diary for
September twenty-ninth.
cue-1175
"Up and away early.
cue-1176
Sorry to leave this lovely camp. I’d have
loved to stay there for a week."
cue-1177
Today, we went straight through a great
mountain barrier, climbing all day through
cue-1178
absolutely beautiful scenery.
cue-1179
One climb in particular took us up the
side of a mountain to avoid a stretch of
cue-1180
sand. The gradient must have been one in
four.
cue-1181
Every day, my idea of what the car can
handle is being challenged. I think
cue-1182
the twin rear wheels have a lot to do with
how well it pulls. Then we reached a
cue-1183
stretch that looked like a massive
highway, smooth as anything, and we sped
cue-1184
along for miles. My speedometer actually
hit thirty-six
cue-1185
MPH. After two weeks of crawling along,
that felt
cue-1186
thrilling. Later, we hit some rough
patches and more of that dreaded
cue-1187
gypsum surface,
cue-1188
but what came next is hard to put into
words. It was, I think,
cue-1189
one of the most beautiful and astonishing
sights I’ve ever seen.
cue-1190
We came over a rise and found ourselves in
a vast basin surrounded by dozens of
cue-1191
little hills, tier upon tier, one black,
one green, one
cue-1192
red, one brown, one yellow, and so on.
Then we entered
cue-1193
what looked like a massive amphitheater
ringed with small hills, but the
cue-1194
floor was covered in wide fan-shaped bands
of color: cobalt, pale
cue-1195
blue, bottle green, light green,
vermilion, brick red,
cue-1196
buff, yellow, white, and more.
cue-1197
I’m no expert on colors. While driving
through it, I turned to Joyce for help,
cue-1198
but he was just as lost as I was. But it
was no illusion.As we passed
cue-1199
through the colored bands, the ground and
stones beneath us really were those
cue-1200
colors. It was truly one of the most
amazing sights I've ever witnessed.
cue-1201
I've heard people talk about the Painted
Desert. Now I've seen it.
cue-1202
At that point,
cue-1203
we were still high in the hills, but the
road ahead of us was magnificent.
cue-1204
For the next sixteen miles or so, we
descended rapidly on a surface that felt
cue-1205
like a racing track, smooth and steady.
cue-1206
My diary ends the day with, "And then to
see trees for the first time in many
cue-1207
days,
cue-1208
beautiful sand dunes, and a real river,
but it is Etsingol."
cue-1209
That was a major moment for us.
cue-1210
We had reached the halfway mark, and from
there on, the road ahead promised to be
cue-1211
far easier.
cue-1212
We left the camel path
cue-1213
and headed toward a small group of four or
five tents, which our guide told us was
cue-1214
the base camp of the Sino-Swedish
expedition.
cue-1215
Our arrival caused quite a stir,
cue-1216
and we received a warm welcome from Dr.
Horner,
cue-1217
to whom we carried a letter of
introduction from a friend in Peiping.
cue-1218
Before long, we were sitting on sheepskin
rugs around a table in Dr.
cue-1219
Horner's tent, enjoying a splendid feast.
It was a real privilege to share
cue-1220
experiences with such a gentleman.
cue-1221
During our conversation, we learned that
Dr. Horner hadn't seen another foreigner
cue-1222
for six months. More troubling, however,
was the news that the rivers we planned to
cue-1223
cross were completely impassable.
Immediately, Dr. Horner offered his
cue-1224
help, placing all twenty-five of his
camels at our disposal and offering
cue-1225
us every assistance. It soon became clear
that we would need to remain at
cue-1226
Oiatoroi for several days, and our host
insisted we use his Mongol
cue-1227
yurt. A yurt can be described, somewhat
simply, as a portable
cue-1228
Mongolian dwelling made of felt over a
light wooden frame.
cue-1229
It was far warmer and more spacious than
our own tent. That's not to speak
cue-1230
badly of our tent. It had stood up well to
storms of wind, rain, and sand and
cue-1231
had truly been a home to us for many days.
But here in Oiatoroi,
cue-1232
we felt like we were living in real
comfort. Dr. Horner would not allow
cue-1233
us to cook for ourselves, insisting
instead that we share meals with him. He
cue-1234
was the picture of generosity. Our time
in the Etsingol
cue-1235
Delta felt like a true holiday, and we
were deeply thankful for it.
cue-1236
My diary entry for October first reads,
"Sitting in my folding chair in real
cue-1237
comfort. In front of me stretches a vast
desert plain with rolling hills in
cue-1238
the distance, each one a different color.
To my right, more desert,
cue-1239
with two small and two large lakes
visible far off. Both large
cue-1240
lakes are ringed with tall trees. Behind
me, beautiful rolling sand
cue-1241
dunes. To my left, a great inland sea
bordered with trees of
cue-1242
every size. It's a perfect scene, a
delight to the eyes. The sight of
cue-1243
water in this dry desert makes you feel
cooler just looking at it, but
cue-1244
I'm glad I don't have to drink it, for
it's all a mirage."
cue-1245
But our days weren't spent entirely in
rest.
cue-1246
We still had serious matters to consider:
how to cross the five rivers of the
cue-1247
Etsingol Valley and how to solve the
critical issue of our dwindling petrol
cue-1248
supply. We also needed to find a new
guide,
cue-1249
as Seret wished to return.
cue-1250
At the camp, we discovered ten five-gallon
petrol tins that had been left by the
cue-1251
Sven Hedin expedition. Through Dr.
Horner's kindness, we were
cue-1252
allowed to purchase these fifty gallons
and arrange payment later at the
cue-1253
headquarters in Peiping.
cue-1254
That amount, we calculated, would at least
be enough to get us to
cue-1255
Hami. You can imagine what this meant to
us.
cue-1256
One great lesson this journey has taught
me is that the Lord has both material and
cue-1257
spiritual resources that we never even
think of.
cue-1258
Oh, that we would learn to trust him more,
to rest in his promises instead of
cue-1259
living under the weight of constant fears,
worries, and cares.
cue-1260
As for crossing the Etsingol Valley, we
faced two main options.
cue-1261
One was to send our goods four or five
days westward by camel, while a few of
cue-1262
us took the empty vehicles around the two
lakes, Sogo Nor and
cue-1263
Gashun Nor, to avoid the rivers. But we
knew that the road around Gashun Nor
cue-1264
was extremely bad, and this route would
add over one hundred miles to our journey,
cue-1265
something our fuel supply simply wouldn't
allow.
cue-1266
The second option was to circle around
just the first lake, avoiding three of
cue-1267
the rivers while sending our goods one day
ahead by Dr. Horner's camels to
cue-1268
a place called Nogan Deli. This plan was
chosen, and it was agreed
cue-1269
that Scherner and Joyce would travel with
the camel caravan.
cue-1270
So on the morning of October fifth, we
unloaded the trucks and transferred our
cue-1271
goods to the camels. That afternoon, we
said goodbye to our cargo and prepared to
cue-1272
depart with the vehicles the next day.
cue-1273
We were sorry to leave the camp, but we
carried with us many happy memories of
cue-1274
those six restful days, and especially of
our generous host, Dr.
cue-1275
Horner.
cue-1276
The first ten miles of the drive around
Sogo Nor were excellent.
cue-1277
After that, though, we had about
twenty-five miles of difficult travel
cue-1278
through alternating belts of gypsum and
sand. Although the surface was smooth,
cue-1279
the engines had to work nearly at full
power the entire time since the
cue-1280
wheels kept sinking deep into the soft
ground. We rarely exceeded fifteen
cue-1281
miles per hour. The weather was warm, and
a tailwind meant the engines
cue-1282
overheated frequently, forcing us to stop
often to let them cool. During one of
cue-1283
these breaks, we took the chance to
explore the old bed of the lake.The ground
cue-1284
was almost entirely white,
cue-1285
a result of heavy salt deposits, and from
a distance it looked like freshly
cue-1286
fallen snow. The lake itself was a
stunning deep blue, something
cue-1287
an artist would be eager to paint.
cue-1288
Strangely, there was no vegetation
anywhere near the lake.
cue-1289
This is because both Sogo Nor and Gashuun
Nor, the Bitter Lake, are
cue-1290
extremely salty.
cue-1291
Animals won't drink the water, and no life
exists in either lake.
cue-1292
For the first thirty-five to forty miles,
we drove due north.
cue-1293
Then,
cue-1294
after rounding the northern end of Sogo
Nor, we turned south again. The road took
cue-1295
us into dense jungle areas, thick with
trees and shrubs,
cue-1296
as this region of the Etsengol Delta is
unusually green.
cue-1297
At times, we had to push our way through
the overgrowth. A few miles before
cue-1298
reaching Nogoon Deli, where we were to
meet the others, we left the camel path
cue-1299
and made a short detour to the Tergot
King's Palace to leave our visiting cards.
cue-1300
Around four PM, we arrived at our meeting
point and found Scherner and
cue-1301
Joyce already waiting for us. They had
thoroughly enjoyed their first camel
cue-1302
journey and reported that the river
crossings had caused them no trouble at
cue-1303
all. According to my diary, the trip
around the lake used about thirty
cue-1304
gallons of petrol and ten gallons of
water, yet we had only covered just over
cue-1305
fifty miles. Ahead of us now lay the
largest of all the rivers, the
cue-1306
Oboingol.
cue-1307
We were told that it had dropped slightly
in the last few days, but it was still
cue-1308
impossible to cross using the vehicles
alone.
cue-1309
After some discussion, we decided to move
our camp closer to the river and wait for
cue-1310
a suitable moment to attempt the crossing.
cue-1311
We returned to Wayal Taroi to borrow
camels from Dr. Horner, who kindly
cue-1312
arranged for them to help us carry both
our cargo and eventually the
cue-1313
cars themselves across the river.
cue-1314
That day, we also said goodbye to Serat.
cue-1315
Though he was eager to return, he later
came back and gave us much-needed help
cue-1316
with the river crossing. He had been an
excellent guide and a tireless worker
cue-1317
throughout our journey.
cue-1318
Sadly, his replacement, a much older
Mongol, didn't quite
cue-1319
measure up.
cue-1320
He was not known for his work ethic.
cue-1321
At first, we gave him the nickname Rastus,
then changed it to Ethelred the
cue-1322
Unready, and finally settled on the more
dignified Sir Galahad, thanks to
cue-1323
Drew.
cue-1324
While we were camped at Nogoon Deli, we
received visits from many Mongols and a
cue-1325
few Chinese. But the most interesting
visit came from the Tergot Mongol
cue-1326
queen and her attendants. She thoroughly
inspected the vehicles and later joined us
cue-1327
in our tent, where I gave her a few
biscuits. Drew brought out the gramophone
cue-1328
and played some records, much to her
amusement. However, when he played
cue-1329
a recording of Dame Clara Butt singing in
her deep contralto voice, the
cue-1330
queen burst into fits of laughter. She and
her party later posed for a
cue-1331
photo. It may seem hard to believe, but it
took us six hours to cover the
cue-1332
three miles between Nogoon Deli and the
Oboingol.
cue-1333
About a mile from camp, we lost our way in
thick undergrowth and didn't reach the
cue-1334
river until after dark. The following day,
Sunday, we rested
cue-1335
in camp. In the evening, we climbed a
nearby hill for a time of prayer and
cue-1336
praise. We couldn't help singing, giving
thanks to the Lord for how faithfully he
cue-1337
had led us. If those hills could speak,
they might have said they had never
cue-1338
before heard the sound of a gospel hymn.
cue-1339
Monday, October eleventh, was the day we
had set for the crossing.
cue-1340
We rose early. My diary reads, "Cars
completely unpacked and
cue-1341
brought to the crossing point.
cue-1342
All electrical components removed or
covered with waterproof sheeting.
cue-1343
Bed of the first car taken off entirely to
reduce weight.
cue-1344
The load was taken over by camels in
relays, done very efficiently.
cue-1345
Then camels were harnessed to the first
car, and off she went.
cue-1346
After several minutes of shouting,
splashing, pushing, and pulling, the
cue-1347
vehicle reached the far bank.
cue-1348
I had expected real difficulty with the
swift current and deep mud, but the second
cue-1349
time the camels knew exactly what to do,
cue-1350
and the next car, with Parsons at the
wheel, almost flew across."
cue-1351
That morning, camp was a hive of activity.
cue-1352
Mr. Hunter was baking scones.
cue-1353
Parsons was preparing a sheep we had
bought for five dollars, while Holmes and
cue-1354
I dismantled the cars.
cue-1355
Across the river, Scherner and Joyce were
working hard to cut down the riverbank
cue-1356
so the vehicles could be driven up it.
Drew handled the receiving of our supplies
cue-1357
as they were ferried over, and Sir
Galahad,
cue-1358
he was sitting by the fire,
cue-1359
smoking his pipe and entertaining visiting
Mongols, completely unbothered.
cue-1360
Reassembly of the vehicles began
immediately, and by midday the following
cue-1361
day, we were packed and ready to continue.
We had been advised to send our goods
cue-1362
by camel across the last of the five
rivers, the Muringol,
cue-1363
some fifty miles further west.
cue-1364
We were told the terrain was too rough for
loaded trucks. After prayer and serious
cue-1365
thought,
cue-1366
we decided not to follow that advice.
cue-1367
Imagine our joy when, by six thirty PM, we
had crossed the Muringol with
cue-1368
little or no difficulty. If we had
followed the suggestion, we would have had
cue-1369
to wait three extra days for the camels
to arrive and pay more expenses. It
cue-1370
was yet another clear sign that the Lord
was guiding us, faithfully answering our
cue-1371
prayers and the prayers of others. On
Wednesday, October twelfth, we
cue-1372
broke all our previous travel records,
cue-1373
covering one hundred and twenty miles in
one day.The final fifteen
cue-1374
miles were driven in the dark,
cue-1375
but our headlights proved strong enough to
let us follow the camel path without
cue-1376
difficulty. That night, we heard wolves
howling nearby, but at no point
cue-1377
during the entire journey was our camp
ever disturbed. I remember Mr.
cue-1378
Soderbom in Peiping once telling me, "The
Gobi is the most peaceful
cue-1379
spot in the world." That's certainly how
it seemed to us. The stillness and
cue-1380
silence of a Gobi night is something that
must be experienced. It
cue-1381
cannot be described.
cue-1382
We later learned that, particularly toward
the end of our journey across the Gobi,
cue-1383
we had been preserved from very real and
present dangers,
cue-1384
things we only discovered after reaching
our destination. But the Lord's
cue-1385
purposes are never hindered when we wait
on Him in quiet, trusting
cue-1386
faith.
cue-1387
Then, on October fourteenth, we crossed
into the province of Sinkiang,
cue-1388
a moment of great significance for us. My
diary entry for that day reads,
cue-1389
"Real wintry blasts, likely due to the
high altitude. Rough
cue-1390
going all morning. We had to constantly
scout for a passable route. Sir
cue-1391
Galahad, our guide, was uncertain and
hesitant. In the
cue-1392
distance, we spotted three camels and
three horses, along with two men.
cue-1393
These were the first living beings we'd
seen in three days. But as we drew
cue-1394
near, the two men suddenly jumped on their
horses and rode off toward the hills as
cue-1395
fast as they could, clearly terrified at
the sight of two huge monsters,
cue-1396
our trucks, coming at speed.
cue-1397
As we passed, we saw the camels and the
remaining horse still standing there,
cue-1398
heavily loaded and calmly waiting,
completely unaware that their
cue-1399
masters had fled.
cue-1400
We were within view of those camels for
nearly an hour, but never saw the men
cue-1401
again." Another diary note reads, "Saw
strange pyramid-like
cue-1402
mounds, about seven of them. This marked
the old customs barrier.
cue-1403
The area was uninhabited, dry, and barren
of any
cue-1404
vegetation.
cue-1405
The only water we could find was brackish
and salty.
cue-1406
We stopped for the night at Mingshui.
cue-1407
The next morning, the thermometer read
fifteen degrees of frost, and the wind was
cue-1408
bitterly cold.
cue-1409
We could hardly turn the engine cranks. It
wasn't until we lit a large fire and
cue-1410
heated water to pour into the radiators
that we were finally able to get the
cue-1411
engine started.
cue-1412
Sunday, October sixteenth.
cue-1413
A glorious scene. The most beautiful
campsite we've had yet, in
cue-1414
a hollow, protected from the northern wind
and just a few yards from a
cue-1415
bubbling mountain stream. To the north
stood the Karlik Mountains,
cue-1416
snow-covered and rising thirteen thousand
feet above us.
cue-1417
To the south
cue-1418
stretched the vast Gobi Plain, looking
like a great sea."
cue-1419
Could there have been a more perfect place
to spend a Sunday?
cue-1420
Yet circumstances made it wise to keep
moving. So, though reluctant,
cue-1421
we packed up and continued our journey.
cue-1422
We entered Hami quietly, without any
announcement, and were able to go
cue-1423
directly to an inn where Mr. Hunter and
the Misses French and Cable had stayed
cue-1424
before. We ended up staying there for two
weeks. During that
cue-1425
time, the innkeeper did everything he
could to make us comfortable.
cue-1426
I was truly amazed by his generosity. He
seemed never to tire of finding
cue-1427
ways to help us.
cue-1428
I was glad I could offer some medical help
to his wife, especially since he firmly
cue-1429
refused any payment in return.
cue-1430
When we arrived in Hami, we had only about
ten gallons of petrol left for each
cue-1431
car,
cue-1432
barely enough to go another sixty miles.
We didn't know the exact distance from
cue-1433
Kalgan to Tihwa,
cue-1434
nor could we estimate how much petrol we
would need.
cue-1435
We simply brought what we thought would be
enough for the whole journey. But the
cue-1436
Lord knew our needs far better than we
did, and at every stage, He
cue-1437
supplied exactly what we required.
cue-1438
Not once did we run short.
cue-1439
And what about the rest of the journey?
cue-1440
Let me repeat what I wrote earlier:
cue-1441
The Lord has sources of supply of which we
little dream.
cue-1442
The road to Kucheung was mostly
uneventful, though still very interesting.
cue-1443
It felt good to be traveling again,
especially in our own
cue-1444
vehicles.
cue-1445
For those interested in the details of the
route,
cue-1446
I'd refer you to the book Through Jade
Gate,
cue-1447
written by the Misses French and Cable.
cue-1448
On page two hundred and nine and
following, they describe the road from
cue-1449
Hami to Tihwa.
cue-1450
If you read it while imagining cars
instead of carts,
cue-1451
you'll have a good sense of what our
journey was like.
cue-1452
We stayed in Kucheung for six days. Then
we made the final leg of the journey,
cue-1453
a wonderful one hundred and thirty miles.
cue-1454
The road was excellent, and it took only
about six hours. At noon
cue-1455
on November ninth, we made our
long-anticipated arrival in
cue-1456
Ürümqi, the capital of Chinese Turkestan.
cue-1457
What a welcome we received from Mr.
Mather. We won't forget it. Our
cue-1458
arrival brought to an end a long season of
waiting for him. That
cue-1459
evening, we gathered together for a time
of prayer and praise. We especially
cue-1460
thanked God for all those around the world
who had faithfully prayed for us. This
cue-1461
letter gives you just a glimpse of what
the Lord did for us, but much remains
cue-1462
unwritten. Still, I can confidently say
the Lord truly answered
cue-1463
your prayers exceeding abundantly. That
evening, Mr. Mather read to
cue-1464
us Psalm one hundred and eighteen, and
how perfectly it described our journey
cue-1465
and all the Lord had brought us
through.And now, before
cue-1466
I end this long letter, I must draw your
attention to one striking and
cue-1467
sobering fact revealed by our journey.
Over the entire one thousand
cue-1468
eight hundred miles we traveled, we passed
only one mission station,
cue-1469
just one place where the gospel of Jesus
Christ is being proclaimed. What about the
cue-1470
people living in the many small villages
we passed through? What of the
cue-1471
tribes scattered across the vast Mongolian
plains?
cue-1472
What of the Mongol communities
concentrated in places like the Etsingol
cue-1473
Delta? And what of the large cities
throughout this province?
cue-1474
How shall they believe in him of whom they
have not heard?
cue-1475
And how shall they hear without a
preacher?
cue-1476
Is this not a call to prayer?
cue-1477
And does it not also come as a personal
challenge to some young people in the
cue-1478
homelands
cue-1479
who are seeking God's will for their
lives?
cue-1480
Pray ye therefore the Lord of the harvest,
that he will send forth laborers
cue-1481
into his harvest.
cue-1482
Chapter six:
cue-1483
Chinese Turkestan.
cue-1484
Chinese Turkestan, now known as Sinkiang,
is that vast region of China
cue-1485
which stretches deep into the heart of
Asia. Its area is roughly equal to
cue-1486
that of Germany, France, and Spain
combined.
cue-1487
It is home to a large and ethnically
diverse population numbering several
cue-1488
millions. The province is remote, hard to
reach, and bordered on
cue-1489
three sides by towering mountain ranges
rising between twenty thousand and
cue-1490
twenty-five thousand feet.
cue-1491
To the east lies the great Mongolian
desert.
cue-1492
To the south stand the Himalayas and the
Tibetan Plateau.
cue-1493
This isolated region has been a cradle of
ancient civilizations and is connected
cue-1494
with famous historical figures like
Genghis Khan and Tamerlane.
cue-1495
For two thousand years, it has remained
under Chinese control despite periods of
cue-1496
violent revolutions and massacres.
cue-1497
Though much of the land is arid, there are
many rich and fertile oases scattered
cue-1498
throughout.
cue-1499
Like Egypt, Sinkiang hides in its sands
the buried treasures of past ages,
cue-1500
greatly prized by archaeologists.
cue-1501
It was only about fifty years ago that it
was formally organized as a separate
cue-1502
province under the name Sinkiang, meaning
new territory.
cue-1503
There is strong evidence that Nestorian
Christianity once flourished throughout
cue-1504
this region. Fragments of ancient
liturgies and several Christian
cue-1505
cemeteries, one of them containing six
hundred twelve gravestones with Syriac
cue-1506
inscriptions, testify to the zeal and
reach of the early church.
cue-1507
Yet Nestorianism, like Buddhism in large
part, eventually gave way to
cue-1508
the vast and forceful spread of Islam.
cue-1509
For many centuries after that, the name of
Christ was no longer heard in these
cue-1510
distant lands.
cue-1511
In more recent times, among the first to
proclaim Christ in the heart of Central
cue-1512
Asia were Dr. Lansdell and Mr. George
Parker, one of the early pioneers
cue-1513
of the China Inland Mission, who came in
eighteen seventy-six.
cue-1514
Even at that early stage, scripture was
being distributed in six languages,
cue-1515
and distant Kolja had been reached.
cue-1516
However, it was not until nineteen oh five
that a central mission station was
cue-1517
established in Urumqi by Mr. George Hunter
of the same mission.
cue-1518
He was later joined by Mr. Mather and more
recently by Mr. Ridley.
cue-1519
Their work has been centered in Tihua, the
Mongolian name for Urumqi, the
cue-1520
capital of the province.
cue-1521
Other efforts have been made in the West.
cue-1522
Swedish missionaries have labored some six
hundred, seven hundred miles further west
cue-1523
in Yarkand and Kashgar. The Roman
Catholic Church also has a presence in the
cue-1524
region.
cue-1525
The population of Sinkiang is incredibly
diverse, making the knowledge of several
cue-1526
languages a real necessity for the
missionary.
cue-1527
Among the many peoples are
cue-1528
Chinese from every province,
cue-1529
Tungans, Chinese-speaking Muslims,
cue-1530
deeply loyal to their faith,
cue-1531
Turkish, called turbanned heads by the
Chinese, who speak their own
cue-1532
Turkic tongue,
cue-1533
Mongols, staunch Buddhists,
cue-1534
Kalmuks, once an independent nation in
Dzungaria,
cue-1535
Kazakhs, Muslim nomads,
cue-1536
Kyrgyz, a distinct Central Asian people,
cue-1537
Nogai, likely descended from Tatar fathers
and European mothers taken captive during
cue-1538
the Tatar invasions.
cue-1539
Manchus, descendants of imperial soldiers
settled there under Emperor
cue-1540
Qianlong.
cue-1541
Russians, many of them refugees fleeing
the Soviet regime.
cue-1542
Such a complex and multilingual audience
gives the missionary full scope to use
cue-1543
every linguistic and cultural gift the
Lord has given.
cue-1544
But to tell the full story of Sinkiang is
beyond our present space.
cue-1545
For those who want to know more, we again
recommend the book Through Jade Gate
cue-1546
mentioned earlier.
cue-1547
For this vast and unevangelized region, an
advance was planned as part of the
cue-1548
China Inland Mission's forward movement.
cue-1549
The men whose journey has been described
in this letter were the first party sent
cue-1550
out under that plan, while some ladies
were appointed to labor in Kansu with a
cue-1551
view to entering Sinkiang later.
cue-1552
It should not be forgotten that the three
women, Evangeline French, Francesca
cue-1553
French, and Mildred Cable,
cue-1554
were the only women ever to undertake
evangelistic work in Eastern Turkestan.
cue-1555
Chinese Turkestan, or Sinkiang as it is
now officially known, stands
cue-1556
as a distant frontier of China, a land
with a stormy
cue-1557
history. Its deep ethnic and religious
divisions have often erupted in
cue-1558
violent conflict, especially between the
Chinese and Muslim populations, leaving a
cue-1559
legacy of bloodshed.More recently, these
tensions have been
cue-1560
worsened by new pressures, the spread of
communist propaganda,
cue-1561
the arrival of tens of thousands of
Russian refugees escaping the harsh
cue-1562
treatment of Soviet agricultural policies,
cue-1563
the rise of armed banditry, with roving
gangs plundering the countryside and even
cue-1564
threatening government forces.
cue-1565
Since the founding of the Republic,
Sinkiang's governors have ruled as
cue-1566
autocrats, adopting an isolationist stance
toward the outside world.
cue-1567
Censorship has been tight.
cue-1568
Chinese newspapers have often been banned,
and at various times it has been
cue-1569
difficult to either enter or leave the
province at all.
cue-1570
The recent Muslim uprisings seem to have
been caused by the harsh and unjust
cue-1571
actions of the former governor. He had
taken land from the people and ignored
cue-1572
long-standing traditions.
cue-1573
Hami, one of the three holy cities in
Chinese Turkestan, is divided
cue-1574
into two forts, one Chinese and one
Muslim.
cue-1575
The Turkic people had been ruled by a line
of Khans going back to the time of
cue-1576
Genghis Khan.
cue-1577
The city's mosque was built in AD fourteen
twenty.
cue-1578
A year or two ago, when the ruling Khan
died, the governor not only refused to
cue-1579
recognize his son, the crown prince, but
imprisoned him and appointed a Chinese
cue-1580
official to rule instead.
cue-1581
The governor also betrayed and killed the
Mongol leader, a living Buddha, and his
cue-1582
two top aides.
cue-1583
This injustice angered both the Turkic and
Mongol peoples, and it was enough to
cue-1584
start a rebellion.
cue-1585
The rebels were supported by a young
Muslim bandit leader, Ma Chong-in, who led
cue-1586
a well-armed group of fellow believers.
cue-1587
This was the tense situation when Emil
Fischbacher and his companions passed
cue-1588
through Hami and entered the provincial
capital.
cue-1589
At that time, Hami was full of military
activity.
cue-1590
Ma Chong-in's forces from Kansu were
important reinforcements for the rebels.
cue-1591
The goal of the rebellion was to overthrow
the governor.
cue-1592
In response, the governor, desperate for
reliable soldiers to strengthen his weak
cue-1593
Chinese troops, forced all the Russians he
could find to join his army.
cue-1594
He managed to gather about two thousand
men. To keep it short, the Russians broke
cue-1595
the five-month siege of Hami, and Ma
Chong-in and his group retreated to Kansu.
cue-1596
That was the state of things when the
travelers passed through Hami and, to the
cue-1597
great surprise of the people, entered the
capital in November nineteen thirty-two.
cue-1598
On Sunday, January the twenty-ninth,
during the morning service, the
cue-1599
congregation in Urumchi, the capital, was
suddenly alarmed by a surprise
cue-1600
attack from Muslim forces.
cue-1601
It's important to note that the local
Muslims lived in the suburbs outside the
cue-1602
city walls.
cue-1603
For several weeks, the city was tightly
sealed off.
cue-1604
Then on January seventeenth, the first
group of Russian troops arrived, followed
cue-1605
by others from Kulja and other places,
eventually totaling around two thousand.
cue-1606
On Tuesday, February the twenty-first,
those staying at the mission house woke to
cue-1607
the sound of gunfire.
cue-1608
Heavy fighting had broken out between the
rebels and the Russians.
cue-1609
After some time, the rebels pulled back,
leaving the local Muslims in the suburbs
cue-1610
to face the terrible consequences. In
brutal fashion, the suburbs were
cue-1611
destroyed, and by the governor's orders,
every man, woman and child was
cue-1612
massacred.
cue-1613
Days of looting followed. By mid-March,
more Russian troops had
cue-1614
arrived.
cue-1615
Most of the soldiers in the province were
now gathered around the city.
cue-1616
These troops brought around three thousand
camels, not carrying food, but
cue-1617
stolen goods.
cue-1618
Alongside them came thousands of Chinese
soldiers who had fled from Japanese forces
cue-1619
in Manchuria by way of Siberia.
cue-1620
These were well-trained troops, much
stronger than the local Chinese forces.
cue-1621
But the governor had angered the Russian
conscripts by the way he treated them.
cue-1622
Meanwhile, the Muslims had offered to stop
fighting if the Russians would hand over
cue-1623
the governor.
cue-1624
On April twelfth, the Russians attacked
the government offices, captured the
cue-1625
governor, and seized the arsenal.
cue-1626
However, the governor managed to escape
and fled across the border into Russian
cue-1627
territory.
cue-1628
A new government was then chosen by a
reconstruction committee.
cue-1629
With Russian and other outside influences,
censorship was lifted and a more
cue-1630
open, progressive government was formed.
cue-1631
Still, many serious problems remained,
cue-1632
making peace with the Muslim population,
cue-1633
stabilizing the currency, and reopening
trade and travel routes.
cue-1634
Sadly, the unrest was not limited to the
capital.
cue-1635
As reported in the public press, cities
like Yarkand, Kashgar, and
cue-1636
others were also caught up in dangerous
uprisings.
cue-1637
This short and incomplete summary should
serve as a background for the letters that
cue-1638
follow.
cue-1639
Sadly, there isn't much written by Dr.
Fischbacher during these difficult months,
cue-1640
apart from the travel account printed in
the last chapter.
cue-1641
As the only trained medical worker
available, besides a Chinese doctor
cue-1642
trained by Dr. Cox and an older Russian
doctor,
cue-1643
he was constantly overwhelmed, working day
and night to treat the many wounded and
cue-1644
neglected soldiers.
cue-1645
Most of his letters were written before
censorship was lifted. Only two letters
cue-1646
written after that point are known to
exist, and both were written three weeks
cue-1647
before his death when he was utterly worn
out from the nonstop demand for his
cue-1648
surgical help.
cue-1649
These were the circumstances in which the
following letters were written.
cue-1650
Chapter seven:
cue-1651
Last letters.
cue-1652
Urumchi, the capital of Sinkiang, was
reached on November the ninth,
cue-1653
eight weeks and one day after leaving
Kalgan by motor.Of that time, only
cue-1654
three weeks and a day were spent
traveling.
cue-1655
The rest, five weeks, was taken up by
delays at various stops.
cue-1656
It was, of course, a great moment when
they finally arrived.
cue-1657
Emil Fischbacher's first letters home
after reaching the city show his joy at
cue-1658
finding a large bundle of mail waiting for
him.
cue-1659
There were around fifty to sixty letters
in all, nearly all from his own family,
cue-1660
making it a real feast of encouragement.
cue-1661
In the East, news spreads quickly, and
though he had hoped to remain unnoticed,
cue-1662
word soon got out that a foreign doctor
was among the new arrivals.
cue-1663
His family had been a bit worried that he
might not take the medical work seriously,
cue-1664
but within two weeks of arriving, he
wrote,
cue-1665
You don't need to worry about the doctor
business. Everybody knows now,
cue-1666
-unfortunately.
-It was an honest statement, as it's never
cue-1667
easy when a medical missionary is
surrounded by patients before having time
cue-1668
to learn the language.
cue-1669
He found it hard not only to study, but
even to write letters.
cue-1670
Less than a month after arriving, he
wrote,
cue-1671
Most of my interruptions are the result of
medical work. I'm doing as little as I
cue-1672
possibly can, but it's almost impossible
to do nothing.
cue-1673
Later in that same letter, he shared
another challenge.
cue-1674
Everything that's a solution had to be
unpacked and moved into my room. Our
cue-1675
average temperature this past week has
been between twenty and twenty-five
cue-1676
degrees below freezing, and it's expected
to drop twenty to thirty degrees lower.
cue-1677
Anything with water in it will freeze
solid. And worst of all,
cue-1678
many of my surgical instruments are
horribly rusty.
cue-1679
Shanghai is terrible for rust.
cue-1680
Even the plating on some is eaten through.
It took me two full days just to get
cue-1681
them all cleaned, greased, and put away
properly.
cue-1682
It's clear someone had asked why they
hadn't traveled by plane instead of by car
cue-1683
across the desert.
cue-1684
In a letter dated December the 17th, 1932,
he replied,
cue-1685
An airplane was here a few days ago, and
the cost of flying to Shanghai was said to
cue-1686
be $1,400 per person,
cue-1687
with only thirty pounds of luggage
allowed. My medical supplies alone weigh
cue-1688
about two hundred pounds. Shipping goods
here by camel takes no less than two
cue-1689
years, and some shipments have taken over
three years to arrive. It's also
cue-1690
very costly to transport goods that way.
cue-1691
We might have considered coming through
the desert by camel caravan, but that
cue-1692
would have required at least forty camels
and taken no less than four
cue-1693
months. As it turned out, if certain
things hadn't delayed us,
cue-1694
we could have arrived in less than a
month.
cue-1695
In the end, we traveled for twenty-two
days.
cue-1696
I expect the total cost will be about half
the price of flying.
cue-1697
While I'm speaking of airplanes, you'll be
glad to know that it's expected we may
cue-1698
soon have a regular service between here
and the coast. That will allow any
cue-1699
urgent letters to reach Shanghai in about
four or five days.
cue-1700
On Tuesday, I hope to perform a small
operation, though unfortunately
cue-1701
under far from ideal conditions.
cue-1702
There is, of course, no hospital here.
Some of the cases are in a pitiful
cue-1703
state.
cue-1704
A man came in two days ago completely
blind. His left eye is entirely
cue-1705
gone. A local barber had kindly scraped it
for him to improve an ulcer.
cue-1706
I needn't say more.
cue-1707
His next letter was written on Christmas
Day, the first he had ever spent away from
cue-1708
home.
cue-1709
Few families have felt the meaning of
Christmas Day more deeply, and he felt the
cue-1710
difference keenly. But a joyful heart
made up for many of the missing signs of
cue-1711
celebration, and in Mr. Mather he found a
kindred spirit.
cue-1712
Mr. Mather, he writes, comes from
Lancashire and is great company.
cue-1713
He's about forty-six, but as young at
heart as any of us. In fact,
cue-1714
he seems younger than I am. It's amazing,
after twenty years in Sinkiang
cue-1715
since we came, the years seem to have
fallen off him, and I know he enjoys
cue-1716
having us here.
cue-1717
As a newcomer, it was natural that he
should write about local conditions.
cue-1718
Some excerpts help us picture them.
cue-1719
There are quite a few foreigners here in
the city who speak English, he says.
cue-1720
Mr. Kierkegaard is Danish, and his wife
Norwegian. He's the postal
cue-1721
commissioner for Sinkiang and speaks
English as well as I do.
cue-1722
Most of the other foreigners are German or
Russian.
cue-1723
On the last day of the year, the first
anniversary of his leaving home,
cue-1724
he wrote more freely to his youngest
sister.
cue-1725
The letter is especially valuable because
it was the last time he had the leisure to
cue-1726
write personally about himself.
cue-1727
The date, December 31st, 1932, he writes,
you will
cue-1728
no doubt recognize. It's exactly a year
since I said goodbye to you at Victoria
cue-1729
Station. What a lot I have to praise God
for today. I feel almost
cue-1730
overwhelmed when I think of all the Lord
has done for me this year. I was saying to
cue-1731
myself the other day how little I've
given up for the Lord, and then it came to
cue-1732
me how wonderful his grace is.
cue-1733
If I had known all this eighteen months
ago, I would have thought the cost too
cue-1734
high, the sacrifices too many. But now I
often stop and ask
cue-1735
myself, what have I really given up for
the Lord? Truly, it is
cue-1736
always like this. I am completely content
and truly happy. I've learned a
cue-1737
little of what it means to look at
difficulties through the Lord, and not at
cue-1738
the Lord through difficulties. There is
absolutely no limit to what the Lord will
cue-1739
do for and through a life fully
surrendered to him.
cue-1740
I truly believe that's the secret, and
it's easy enough to say, but another
cue-1741
thing to live it. It's only through the
Holy Spirit's help that real surrender is
cue-1742
possible,
cue-1743
and surrender must be distinguished from
simple resignation to God's
cue-1744
will.It's not a passive thing. It's deeply
active,
cue-1745
based on a strong faith that God will
accept the offering and use it for His
cue-1746
glory alone. That is one of the greatest
lessons I'm learning these days.
cue-1747
This long letter, written only for his
sister, shows the heart of a man
cue-1748
eager to go all the way with God.
cue-1749
It reveals a holy dissatisfaction with
anything in his own life or in others
cue-1750
that fell short of the highest.
cue-1751
He admitted that in argument he often
failed, but this did not lessen his desire
cue-1752
for spiritual depth.
cue-1753
I'm no theologian, he writes, and I always
lose every argument and get beaten
cue-1754
in every discussion.
cue-1755
Yet, like the deer that longs for the
water brooks, his soul longed for
cue-1756
God.
cue-1757
In this spirit, he ended the last day of
the last full year of his life.
cue-1758
On January sixth, he picked up his pen
again and wrote,
cue-1759
Well, here goes for my first letter in
nineteen thirty-three. I wonder how
cue-1760
many letters this year will begin with
this address. There's no telling.
cue-1761
A week later, after noting how hard he
found it after his busy life as a doctor
cue-1762
at home to settle down to steady study, he
described local conditions
cue-1763
-and what had been accomplished.
-With all these different nationalities, we
cue-1764
mix freely, and I've already met people
of every kind.
cue-1765
Although, as you know, I can't speak
German,
cue-1766
I can understand almost everything that's
said, and that's been a great help.
cue-1767
Otto Schörner, of course, speaks German,
so we often have the pleasure of
cue-1768
entertaining quite a few people.
Cossacks, Turkish, Mongols, and
cue-1769
Chinese all attend the services regularly,
though for now only Chinese
cue-1770
services are held. There are also Manchus
in this province.
cue-1771
Mr. Hunter and Mr. Mather have done a
great deal of translation work,
cue-1772
dictionaries, Pilgrim's Progress, and
parts of Scripture into nearly
cue-1773
all the local languages.
cue-1774
No work has yet been done among the
Manchus,
cue-1775
but it is hoped someone will take that on.
As you can imagine, it
cue-1776
requires a special language, and it takes
years of study and practice to gain real
cue-1777
skill in it. It is almost impossible for
anyone to work in this province
cue-1778
without knowing at least two languages.
cue-1779
Mr. Mather speaks Chinese fluently, as
well as Kalmuck Mongol.
cue-1780
He can preach in both and has a special
interest in work among the Mongols. He
cue-1781
also speaks some Turkey, though he never
formally studied it. He
cue-1782
simply learned through daily contact with
the people. He also knows a bit of
cue-1783
Russian.
cue-1784
Mr. Hunter and Mr. Mather produced a
Manchu dictionary some years ago
cue-1785
and translated Pilgrim's Progress into
Turkey.
cue-1786
So, as you can see, much has already been
done, though there is still plenty of
cue-1787
scope for more workers of the same kind.
cue-1788
The church is full every Sunday. It's
wonderful to see, but that isn't
cue-1789
everything. What we long for is a greater
increase in the number of those who
cue-1790
boldly take their stand for Jesus Christ.
That is not an easy thing here,
cue-1791
especially among the Muslims.
cue-1792
As much as Emil Fischbacher longed to
study the languages himself, his medical
cue-1793
work made it nearly impossible.
cue-1794
-He often mentioned this in his letters.
-Will you forgive a letter with no news? He
cue-1795
writes.
cue-1796
I'm very,
cue-1797
very busy,
cue-1798
but study is impossible.
cue-1799
Yesterday, I had a rather serious
operation. I removed a bullet from a man's
cue-1800
chest.
cue-1801
It had passed through the right lung just
above the heart.
cue-1802
I suspected it had broken a rib behind and
found that it had.
cue-1803
It was embedded in a mass of splinters.
The patient is doing well. These
cue-1804
operations aren't easy without an X-ray,
but one learns to do without such
cue-1805
-luxuries.
-On February nineteenth, just three days
cue-1806
before rebels attacked the city, a siege
that would plunge him into intense
cue-1807
surgical work until the end,
cue-1808
he lamented the lack of a hospital.
cue-1809
In an earlier letter, he had asked his
family to imagine a town of seventy
cue-1810
thousand people with no drainage system.
cue-1811
He grieved over the yearly loss of life
from typhoid, typhus, dysentery,
cue-1812
diphtheria, and scarlet fever,
cue-1813
little realizing that within months he
himself would be numbered among the dead.
cue-1814
Nor did he know when he wrote the
following lines that within three days
cue-1815
hundreds of wounded soldiers would be in
desperate need of hospital care.
cue-1816
Can you imagine, he writes, a city of
seventy thousand people without a
cue-1817
hospital?
cue-1818
Try to picture such a place, and then
you'll understand why I'm not left in
cue-1819
peace to study. The nearest hospital is
forty-five days' journey away.
cue-1820
If I went there, it would take over fifty
days, since I wouldn't travel on Sundays.
cue-1821
That hospital is in Kashgar, in the
southwest of the province. My
cue-1822
nearest CIM neighbors are at the hospital
in Lanzhou, over sixty days' journey
cue-1823
away.
cue-1824
Half a million square miles makes quite a
large medical district, don't you
cue-1825
-think?
-On February twentieth, less than
cue-1826
twenty-four hours before the surprise
attack, he wrote again.
cue-1827
Another interruption. This is quite the
place. Mr. Mather just came to show
cue-1828
me his tent. It has finally arrived, and
it's a fine one. But listen to
cue-1829
its story. Last April, perhaps earlier, I
told you about some goods
cue-1830
that had left Shanghai over two years ago
and still hadn't arrived.
cue-1831
Well, they've finally come. Eight boxes in
all. Most of them
cue-1832
contain tracts and gospels in various
languages and had long been given up as
cue-1833
lost.
cue-1834
They've been three and a half years on the
way. They came by camel through
cue-1835
Mongolia but were seized and taken to
Urga.Later
cue-1836
they were sent on again,
cue-1837
but delayed many times by local troubles.
cue-1838
Finally,
cue-1839
the caravan of many camels reached Taiwa
yesterday.
cue-1840
So Mr. Mather is rejoicing. That's how
things work here.
cue-1841
From the letters that followed, little can
be learned about what was really
cue-1842
happening. Because of censorship, he could
not mention that the city was under siege
cue-1843
by Muslim rebels.
cue-1844
In a letter written on February 25th, four
days after the attack began,
cue-1845
there is not a single word about it. The
same is true of the letter written a week
cue-1846
later. Its main topic was his photographs
of the Gobi Desert. He dared
cue-1847
not send the films by post for fear of
losing them, yet at that very time he was
cue-1848
tirelessly working among the wounded.
cue-1849
A month later, on March 25th, he wrote,
cue-1850
I'm sorry there's been almost a month's
gap in my letters, but I can assure you
cue-1851
it's not from laziness. I've been very
busy,
cue-1852
morning, noon and night.
cue-1853
I'm operating as much as I possibly can
every day. The other fellows are doing the
cue-1854
dressings and working like Trojans.
They've been splendid. All the cases
cue-1855
are the result of battle injuries,
amputations, all kinds of repairs.
cue-1856
I've treated empyemas and set fractures.
cue-1857
I've had six broken femurs,
cue-1858
three broken forearms,
cue-1859
three broken upper arms, and several cases
of pierced bladders, chests
cue-1860
and abdomens,
cue-1861
-all caused by bullets.
-There was not a single word about what the
cue-1862
fighting was, though anyone reading
between the lines could guess.
cue-1863
The hard work went on.
cue-1864
The next letter is dated
cue-1865
April the 6th.
cue-1866
I've almost forgotten how to write
letters, he says. It's been over a month
cue-1867
since I last wrote, except for one short
note on March 25th.
cue-1868
I suddenly had a chance to send a letter
by airmail, so I wrote a quick, messy
cue-1869
one. I'm very, very busy, and not with
study.
cue-1870
I'm operating a great deal now, almost as
much as I possibly can.
cue-1871
The other men are looking after the wards
and call me in whenever needed.
cue-1872
We now have over 300 patients.
cue-1873
I can understand now what the surgeons in
France went through during the war of
cue-1874
1914 and after.
cue-1875
How thankful I am for my earlier
experience.
cue-1876
The others are working heroically too,
cue-1877
doing dressings as large as any I ever did
at home. The staff have risen to the
cue-1878
challenge wonderfully. We now have plenty
of opportunities to learn the spoken
cue-1879
language, though study itself is at a
standstill.
cue-1880
More importantly, we have wonderful
chances to share the gospel with these
cue-1881
people. After all, healing their bodies is
not enough.
cue-1882
What is needed is a deep change of heart.
cue-1883
Then work like this would no longer be
necessary. I have seen many stirring
cue-1884
times since I came to China last February,
but none like these. We are all well
cue-1885
and happy, and we long for letters from
home.
cue-1886
As mentioned earlier, the local government
was overthrown on April 12th when the
cue-1887
Russians captured the arsenal and took the
governor prisoner.
cue-1888
The censorship ended at that time, so
later letters could be written more
cue-1889
freely. Five days after the governor's
fall, though extremely busy, he
cue-1890
wrote to his youngest sister, giving a
detailed account.
cue-1891
Of the letters we still have, this is the
second to last from his hand, and in it he
cue-1892
-says
-I want to talk medicine. I wish I could
cue-1893
start at the beginning, he writes, and
tell you everything that has happened, but
cue-1894
that's impossible just now.
cue-1895
The censorship seems to be gone for the
moment, so I long to tell you all. These
cue-1896
have been stirring days, but the Lord has
wonderfully protected us.
cue-1897
We were never afraid,
cue-1898
even while bullets were flying around.
I've gathered quite a collection of
cue-1899
bullets now, my own souvenirs from these
troubles. At first I wasn't
cue-1900
eager to help in the hospitals, because my
language skills were still poor. But in
cue-1901
the end, the others and Mr. Mather agreed
to assist Dr. Marr, a Chinese
cue-1902
doctor.
cue-1903
Later, at the request of the former
governor, I agreed to take on any urgent
cue-1904
or serious cases.
cue-1905
I arranged for the five men and Mr. Mather
to do the dressings and care
cue-1906
for the patients I had operated on. All
the wounds were from bullets or swords.
cue-1907
The wounded kept coming, and the work
increased.
cue-1908
I had a fine little operating room, with
Otto as my assistant and two Chinese
cue-1909
boys to help.
cue-1910
Dr. Marr and sometimes Mr. Mather gave the
anesthetics.
cue-1911
Later, a Roman Catholic priest, who is
quite skilled medically,
cue-1912
took charge of about 30 patients, and I
performed any operations he needed me to
cue-1913
-do.
-He then went on to give a detailed, and at
cue-1914
times gruesome, account of the wounds he
treated.
cue-1915
The letter was written to his sister, who
was a doctor, but many readers would not
cue-1916
wish to read such descriptions.
cue-1917
It showed how dreadful the injuries from a
sword's slash or a bullet's impact could
cue-1918
be.
cue-1919
When I first went to the hospital, he
writes, I found five compound fractures of
cue-1920
the thigh bone, all in dreadful
condition. The filth and stench of the
cue-1921
place were beyond description. Imagine
300 wounds, large and
cue-1922
small, left unattended for two weeks or
more. It was a horrifying
cue-1923
experience.
cue-1924
He used the word terrific more than once
in the letter. It truly was both terrible
cue-1925
and overwhelming.
cue-1926
The letter ended with a short postscript.
cue-1927
I'm now in charge of a new hospital,
opened three weeks ago.
cue-1928
The other men each have charge of a ward,
and I'm working as hard as I possibly can.
cue-1929
With no equipment and little or no
medicine,
cue-1930
one learns to be inventive.
cue-1931
The fighting had lasted for several days,
and as around ten thousand rebels attacked
cue-1932
the city, it was shut off for about six
weeks.
cue-1933
Thousands were reported killed, and the
battlefield outside the city was a sight
cue-1934
that could never be forgotten.
cue-1935
Then came the last letter he ever wrote
home, dated May sixth, nineteen
cue-1936
thirty-three.
cue-1937
It began,
cue-1938
"These days, I'm sorry to say, I have
absolutely no ambition,
cue-1939
not even the desire to write to you all.
cue-1940
The fact is, I've been out of action for
three days now, and I simply can't find
cue-1941
the energy to write." Though he did not
realize it,
cue-1942
this was likely the beginning of the
illness that would prove fatal. He
cue-1943
continued,
cue-1944
"I don't have a moment to call my own.
That's the real reason I've been laid up.
cue-1945
One night, I had to go outside the city
very late and didn't have time to dress
cue-1946
properly. I was given a fine horse and
went with a Russian officer, two
cue-1947
soldiers, and one of the leaders of the
White Russians. The horse was very
cue-1948
spirited and tried several times to throw
me. He flew like the wind.
cue-1949
When I reached my destination, I was
drenched with sweat. The
cue-1950
evenings here are quite cold, though the
days are already very hot. On the
cue-1951
return journey, we had to wait about half
an hour for the city gates to be opened.
cue-1952
There are guards everywhere inside and
outside the city, and I would have been
cue-1953
shot instantly if not for the soldiers who
knew the password. Getting into the
cue-1954
city at night is no easy matter. During
that wait, I must have caught a
cue-1955
chill. Added to that, I was working so
hard that I wasn't getting enough
cue-1956
sleep. There are four hundred wounded
spread across three hospitals,
cue-1957
and I was caring for one hundred and
twenty-five of the worst cases in a
cue-1958
hospital I had organized myself." He wrote
that many of these men had not been
cue-1959
washed for one, two, or even three months
before they came under his care.
cue-1960
The condition of their wounds, clothes,
and bedding was almost beyond
cue-1961
imagination. "Not one official," he added,
"has ever come to
cue-1962
inspect our work or even see what we are
doing."
cue-1963
Worse still, the authorities failed to
provide food for the patients or wages for
cue-1964
the Chinese staff.
cue-1965
As a result, the Chinese workers went on
strike, leaving the already
cue-1966
overworked foreigners to handle everything
themselves.
cue-1967
"It has shown me the inner side of Chinese
life in just three months," he wrote.
cue-1968
"Without this experience, it would have
taken years.
cue-1969
I now hold consultations in English,
Russian, German,
cue-1970
Chinese, Mongol, Turkey, Manchu, and
Cossack.
cue-1971
Today, even two Poles came to see me.
Thankfully, they knew some Chinese.
cue-1972
I can manage medical consultations in
Chinese on my own now. I know a fair bit
cue-1973
of Russian and can ask simple questions in
that language,
cue-1974
and in Mongol and Cossack too. In my
hospital, I have Mongols.
cue-1975
Mr. Mather looks after them as he speaks
Mongol well.
cue-1976
Chantos, Turkey people,
cue-1977
Tungans,
cue-1978
and of course, Chinese."
cue-1979
Overwhelmed, he wrote, "I simply cannot
care for the whole population of Tihwa.
cue-1980
When I refuse a case, I am often cursed.
cue-1981
You might ask, 'Why do it?' But if you saw
the condition of these men,
cue-1982
you couldn't help but do something."
cue-1983
This was his final letter.
cue-1984
Even the parts that can be printed barely
suggest the full reality of what he
cue-1985
experienced.
cue-1986
Much cannot be published.
cue-1987
Though censorship had been lifted, a
missionary cannot freely share all he sees
cue-1988
and knows.
cue-1989
His position is one of trust.
cue-1990
That Emil Fischbacher gave his life
through tireless labor is clearly shown in
cue-1991
what has been written here.
cue-1992
[gentle music] Chapter eight:
cue-1993
Faithful unto death.
cue-1994
Exactly three weeks after the Saturday
when Emil Fischbacher wrote his last
cue-1995
letter, he laid down his life for God and
for others in the land he had come to
cue-1996
love.
cue-1997
In the words of Christina Rossetti, if we
may change a pronoun, it was,
cue-1998
"One step more, and the goal receives him.
cue-1999
One word more, and life's task is done.
One toil more, and the cross is
cue-2000
carried and sets the sun."
cue-2001
Emil Fischbacher had obeyed the heavenly
call.
cue-2002
He had learned the joy of serving and the
peace of full surrender.
cue-2003
His heart burned with zeal for his
master's cause and for the salvation of
cue-2004
souls.
cue-2005
He was faithful unto death.
cue-2006
Though still unwell, as mentioned in his
last letter, he returned to his work among
cue-2007
the sick and dying.
cue-2008
Five days later, he collapsed and had to
be put to bed.
cue-2009
Two days before this, Mr. Mather had also
been confined to bed with fever.
cue-2010
In that lonely mission outpost, Mr.
Hunter, already over seventy years
cue-2011
old, and the five new workers gathered
around the two sick beds, caring for them
cue-2012
with deep love and devotion. Whether the
illness was typhus or typhoid was
cue-2013
uncertain, both to the doctor himself and
to those who nursed
cue-2014
him. Yet all human care was powerless to
save them.
cue-2015
Mr. Mather went home to be with the Lord
on May twenty-fourth, and Emil Fischbacher
cue-2016
followed three days later.
cue-2017
To the east of the city, in sight of the
mountains, they were laid to rest side by
cue-2018
side.
cue-2019
The land for which they gave their lives
holds their dust until the great trumpet
cue-2020
of God shall sound.
cue-2021
Then their mortal bodies will be clothed
with immortality, and the promise will be
cue-2022
fulfilled.
cue-2023
Death is swallowed up in victory.
cue-2024
Therefore, my beloved brothers, be
steadfast, immovable, always
cue-2025
abounding in the work of the Lord, knowing
that your labor is not in vain in the
cue-2026
Lord.Chapter nine.
cue-2027
To what purpose?
cue-2028
It was on the last Saturday in May
nineteen thirty-one that Emil Fischbacher
cue-2029
picked up China's Millions and read the
Appeal to Young Men.
cue-2030
On the last Saturday in May nineteen
thirty-three, exactly two years later,
cue-2031
his earthly service ended,
cue-2032
and he returned to God who had called him.
cue-2033
The call to leave home came in one way.
cue-2034
The call to leave his work in China came
in another, only two years apart. Such a
cue-2035
brief span stirs the mind and raises deep
questions. To what purpose was
cue-2036
the first call if the second was to follow
so soon?
cue-2037
How should life's worth be measured?
cue-2038
Can we measure life by years alone?
cue-2039
Is length of time of little value in the
light of eternity? What did Emil
cue-2040
Fischbacher himself think about his
service?
cue-2041
What did his loved ones feel? And what can
we say? The things of the
cue-2042
spirit cannot be measured by human
standards.
cue-2043
It is good sometimes to pause and think
deeply. Was the poet right who said,
cue-2044
"Measure thy life by loss instead of gain,
cue-2045
not by the wine drunk but the wine poured
forth"?
cue-2046
It is fitting now to look again at that
appeal to young men which came to young
cue-2047
Fischbacher as God's call.
cue-2048
One paragraph will suffice.
cue-2049
"If ease and comfort at home hold you back
from suffering for Christ in China, then
cue-2050
much of what you accomplish at home will
not endure at the judgment seat of Christ.
cue-2051
But if you do the will of God, and if that
will means China for you, your life will
cue-2052
never be lost. It will live forever in
soul-saving work."
cue-2053
These are striking words, especially those
at the end of the statement.
cue-2054
But is it true that if God chose China for
Emil Fischbacher, his life will never
cue-2055
end but will remain forever in soul-saving
work?
cue-2056
Is this simply poetic language or plain
truth?
cue-2057
Two verses from scripture answer that
question.
cue-2058
Our Lord himself said,
cue-2059
"Not everyone who says to me, 'Lord,
Lord,' shall enter the kingdom of heaven,
cue-2060
but only those who do the will of my
Father in heaven."
cue-2061
And through his servant John, he said,
cue-2062
"The world passes away and its desires,
cue-2063
but whoever does the will of God lives
forever."
cue-2064
Do we believe this?
cue-2065
One of the most respected men in the
church today recently said-
cue-2066
"I believe the greatest weakness in every
church is the inability to take Jesus
cue-2067
Christ seriously and to take him at his
word."
cue-2068
Another writer from a very different
background expressed it this way.
cue-2069
"The truth is, the Galilean has been too
great for our small hearts."
cue-2070
Emil Fischbacher had no doubts about the
wisdom and joy of obedience.
cue-2071
Writing to his youngest brother from the
heart of Asia, fully aware of its
cue-2072
difficulties,
cue-2073
he declared his confidence that God had
guided him in every detail.
cue-2074
Speaking of his delays at home and the
wide medical experience he had gained, he
cue-2075
wrote-
cue-2076
"Yes, I did move about a great deal, and I
can't help thinking that from that
cue-2077
point of view, the timing of my call was
just right."
cue-2078
Then, referring to his journey across the
Gobi Desert, he continued.
cue-2079
"But there is something even more
convincing. It's the fact of the journey
cue-2080
up here."
cue-2081
Recalling, as one brother might to
another, his experience with motor
cue-2082
vehicles and the responsibilities he had
carried, he added.
cue-2083
"Such expeditions are usually planned by
men with long experience in that kind
cue-2084
of travel.
cue-2085
Well, the story of our journey is proof
enough of the Lord's wonderful
cue-2086
leading. I don't know of a single thing we
left behind,
cue-2087
though to have forgotten something in the
Gobi might have been fatal.
cue-2088
And I say this humbly and only to you,
cue-2089
I believe the Lord delayed my call for
just such a time as this.
cue-2090
It was work I thoroughly enjoyed, and I
believe, humanly speaking,
cue-2091
I was somewhat fitted for it.
cue-2092
Let that encourage you. The Lord may seem
a little late to our weak senses,
cue-2093
but even if the explanation is delayed or
never given, I
cue-2094
know the truth will always prove true."
cue-2095
Such was his testimony.
cue-2096
His letters show no trace of regret, only
joy in doing his father's will.
cue-2097
In Shanghai, during prayer with his
missionary sister, he thanked God for his
cue-2098
gracious guidance and then exclaimed with
simple sincerity.
cue-2099
"Lord, it has not been hard at all. None
of it. You've done
cue-2100
magnificently."
cue-2101
But did his family regret it?
cue-2102
Let us hear first from his sister in
China.
cue-2103
Her letter not only shows her heart, but
also reflects something of what her
cue-2104
brother believed about second causes.
cue-2105
"When I received the telegram," she wrote,
"telling me that we would never meet
cue-2106
again on Earth, the Lord gave me a share
in my brother's joy and a share in
cue-2107
his own far greater joy as he welcomed
his beloved servant home.
cue-2108
My heart echoed the refrain,
cue-2109
'You've done magnificently.'
cue-2110
Worthy is the Lamb that was slain to
receive power and riches and
cue-2111
wisdom and strength and honor and glory
and blessing.
cue-2112
While I was in Shanghai, my brother and I
talked about the question of second
cue-2113
causes. They were no problem to him.
cue-2114
In a letter received just after he went
home, though written as far back as
cue-2115
-February fifth, he said..."
-"Oh, I'm so grateful that I have learned
cue-2116
to take everything from the Lord."
cue-2117
-That same letter says...
-"You are always looking for a new thing.
cue-2118
I too have learned something of the
blessing that comes when we break away
cue-2119
from the old pattern of stagnation.
cue-2120
Isn't it amazing,
cue-2121
the endless supply of new things?"
cue-2122
Isn't it wonderful to realize that the
promise in Isaiah 43
cue-2123
is always living and unfailing? Oh, how
poor we make ourselves by not
cue-2124
claiming his promises.
cue-2125
I've been discovering many unclaimed
promises in my reading lately.
cue-2126
Little did he imagine what a glorious new
thing God had waiting for him just a
cue-2127
little further along the road.
cue-2128
From every point of view I am satisfied
with God's choice for him, completely
cue-2129
satisfied.
cue-2130
I would never have dared to choose
anything so good for him,
cue-2131
but I am glad that the one who loves him
far more than I do made the choice.
cue-2132
Bless the Lord, O my soul, and all that is
within me,
cue-2133
bless his holy name.
cue-2134
O magnify the Lord with me, and let us
exalt his name together.
cue-2135
Lord, it has not been hard at all, none of
it. You've done
cue-2136
magnificently.
cue-2137
In that letter from my brother, received
after his home call, he spoke of the
cue-2138
vastness of the task and the special
difficulties of the work in Sinkiang, then
cue-2139
referred to the promise of the rivers of
living water, adding,
cue-2140
I have not been able to find any condition
under which that supply is ever to be
cue-2141
stopped, but I do fully believe that this
kind goeth not out
cue-2142
but by prayer and fasting.
cue-2143
Do you think God intended the flow of
those living waters to be reduced by
cue-2144
taking two of his children from that
thirsty land?
cue-2145
I believe their going is part of his plan
to increase that flow. And I believe that
cue-2146
truth carries a message for some of you.
cue-2147
That is why I have shared so much.
cue-2148
I make no special appeal for Sinkiang or
for any place,
cue-2149
though one of my sorrows is that I can
answer only one of the many calls that
cue-2150
echo in my ears.
cue-2151
The need is so great and the workers so
few.
cue-2152
But I do make an appeal for my Lord, the
one who gave his life and who still
cue-2153
gives it for us.
cue-2154
Will you give yourself wholly to him?
cue-2155
He will do magnificently for you,
cue-2156
and he is worthy.
cue-2157
And their father at home wrote to the
author,
cue-2158
This news came to us as a great shock, but
it was not long before
cue-2159
we could look up again to the blue sky,
listen to the song of the birds,
cue-2160
and hear the music of the eternal in our
souls.
cue-2161
We are content to trust him who has so
graciously helped, blessed,
cue-2162
and upheld us until now. We have often
prayed
cue-2163
that the Lord would make Emil's life and
service fruitful for his glory, and we
cue-2164
gladly leave to him the way he has chosen
to answer that prayer.
cue-2165
And last but not least,
cue-2166
Emil Fischbacher's youngest brother
accepted both his brother's death and the
cue-2167
needs of the mission field as a personal
challenge.
cue-2168
He offered himself to take, as far as
possible, his brother's place.
cue-2169
We share these deeply personal details
only for the glory of Emil Fischbacher's
cue-2170
God. It should also be mentioned that
another doctor and his wife have
cue-2171
volunteered to serve in that same distant
region. When news of Dr.
cue-2172
Fischbacher's death reached England, less
than seven months after his arrival in
cue-2173
Sinkiang, many asked, To what purpose was
this life poured out?
cue-2174
Here was a young man, bright, capable, and
full of promise,
cue-2175
thoroughly trained for medical service,
one of the few doctors in a vast land,
cue-2176
and yet called home so soon, just as his
life's work had begun.
cue-2177
It is easy for us to dwell on what might
have been.
cue-2178
But the words of Christ, spoken in Bethany
in the house of Simon the Leper,
cue-2179
remind us that God's judgments are not
like ours, nor his thoughts like ours.
cue-2180
He alone can rightly measure the worth of
a life.
cue-2181
It is a remarkable fact that at the
farewell meeting in London for Emil
cue-2182
Fischbacher and his companions, the last
group of the two hundred to set sail,
cue-2183
the Reverend W. H. Aldis spoke on the
story of the alabaster box
cue-2184
of precious ointment.
cue-2185
He drew attention to the sharp contrast
between the disciples' reaction,
cue-2186
To what purpose is this waste? and our
Lord's response,
cue-2187
She hath wrought a beautiful thing unto
me. Liddell and Scott's
cue-2188
lexicon translates the Greek word kalos as
something fair, lovely,
cue-2189
morally right, and beautiful.
cue-2190
That contrast between human judgment and
God's continues to this day, except as
cue-2191
we learn to see life in his light.
cue-2192
The fragrance of that ointment poured from
the broken vessel filled the house, and
cue-2193
the devotion that prompted the gift filled
and satisfied the heart of Christ.
cue-2194
But Judas, along with others who resented
such lavish love, protested,
cue-2195
To what purpose has this waste been made?
cue-2196
With deep irony, Jesus later spoke of
Judas as the son of perdition,
cue-2197
literally the son of waste, for the same
Greek word is used in both
cue-2198
expressions. And what a true son of waste
Judas was.
cue-2199
He embodied the very fault he imagined he
saw in Mary.
cue-2200
How terribly he had squandered his
opportunities. How he had misused the
cue-2201
privileges and profaned the blessings that
had been given to him. Lifted to the
cue-2202
heights of fellowship with Christ, he cast
himself down to ruin by wasting the
cue-2203
riches of grace offered to him.
cue-2204
Nowhere in Scripture do we find a more
vivid and solemn contrast between
cue-2205
God's and man's standards of value.
cue-2206
As we think of Emil Fischbacher's life
poured out for God,
cue-2207
we remember the lesson of the precious
ointment and the words of Christ.
cue-2208
Whoever desires to save his life will lose
it, but whoever loses his life for my
cue-2209
sake and the gospel's will save it.
cue-2210
It is surely significant that this is the
only one of our Lord's sayings recorded in
cue-2211
all four Gospels.
cue-2212
Nor is that its only distinction.
cue-2213
With meaningful variations, Jesus spoke
these words on at least four
cue-2214
different occasions.
cue-2215
When he sent out the twelve, when he
rebuked Peter for urging him to turn aside
cue-2216
from the cross, and twice again as his
earthly ministry neared its end and he
cue-2217
faced death in its most painful form.
cue-2218
Slow as we are to believe and understand,
this is God's law of life. We
cue-2219
ask, to what purpose?
cue-2220
Christ answers,
cue-2221
it is a beautiful thing and one that
brings forth much fruit.
cue-2222
Epilogue
cue-2223
Sorrow of saints is sorrow of a day.
Gladness of saints is gladness
cue-2224
evermore.
cue-2225
Send on thy hope, send on thy will before
to chant God's praise along the
cue-2226
narrow way.
cue-2227
Stir up his praises if the flesh would
sway. Exalt his praises if the world press
cue-2228
sore. Peel out his praises if black Satan
roar a hundred thousand lies to
cue-2229
say them nay.
cue-2230
Devil and death and Hades, threefold cord.
cue-2231
Not quickly broken, front thee to thy
face.
cue-2232
Front thou them with a face of tenfold
flint. Shout for the battle, David.
cue-2233
Never stint body or breath or blood, but
proof in grace die for thy
cue-2234
Lord as once for thee thy Lord.
cue-2235
Christina Rossetti
cue-2236
This audiobook was produced by
scrollreader.com.
cue-2237
We would also encourage you to listen to
George Hunter, Apostle of
cue-2238
Turkestan, the biography of the man Emil
went to serve with.